Biden is officially backing away from
the mask enforcement on airlines after a
Court ruling Struck it down now the
funny thing is earlier today at the
Press briefing the uh genseki was
actually asked about this and she's like
well we're still going to recommend it
and when Peter Ducey was like you know
why why would you recommend masks but
here in this room we don't got to wear
them she's like are you a Doctor Peter
are you a doctor I'm not a doctor and
then Peter I think he said and and I
don't play what nor do I play one on TV
haha but it's really funny that's like
going to be the go-to answer now for
anything ever in politics is that you
don't actually have any expertise so you
can't answer any questions but here we
go there's actually big news uh now
apparently if you want to fly if you're
ready to fly right now they're saying
they're not enforcing it so it's going
to be a shock to a lot of flight
attendants and Pilots when people all
just take their masks off throw them in
the air like it's graduation I wonder
how many people are still going to
actually keep their masks on we got
other news too Alex Jones reportedly
filed for bankruptcy but he's saying he
didn't actually file for bankruptcy he's
filing for chapter 11 reorganization but
now it's just framing because that's
still under bankruptcy laws but he's
saying he's doing this that the feds can
look at his books to see that he's not
hiding any money which is interesting
we'll get into all that stuff plus we
got a bunch of crazy stories Rhonda
Santos he's he's pulling Florida pulled
a whole bunch of math books because they
had critical race theory in them and the
left is freaking out but the question is
why do math books have critical race
theory in them anyway some other
interesting news Jon Stewart's new show
has flopped good get what go broke there
it is so we'll talk about all of that
joining us today is Braxton McCoy
thanks for having me Tim would you like
to introduce yourself sure I am a horse
trainer author of this book The Glass
Factory about getting wounded in Iraq
and then coming home and starting over
and I also run this program called the
bunk house where we bring people in and
teach them skills first aid skills field
medical stuff we take them hunting uh
back country stuff just kind of like
trying to teach the skills that
appreciate over so we're kind of like
almost like the grandpa some people
needed to have when they were younger
but just doing it for them as an adult
oh right on glad to have you man I'll
just mention too we have a headphone
exception for a cowboy hats that's right
John John rich last week and thank you
God bless you John
right on and we're hanging out with
Brett dasovic how's it going everybody I
am Brett dasovich the host of Pop
Culture crisis we actually just finished
uh filming the 100th episode today and
that will come out tomorrow so I am uh
hope you guys check that out and I'm
glad to be here youtube.com pop culture
crisis one of the new shows from
timcast.com yes we got Ian hi everybody
we're back and it feels good to be home
I'll tell you that I rolled in 81 if it
means anything to you on the 100-sided
die so let's get rolling very cool I am
very glad to be back here with my
familiar cameras hopefully I don't make
any more camera mistakes or mic mistakes
hopefully uh our next trip will be much
smoother I'm really looking forward to
that already and uh before we get
started I just want to have a moment of
silence for all of our uh business
owners today because it is tax day and
I'm sure all of you have been
collectively punched in the gut when uh
your accounts came back and said oh
here's what you owe and you're like
oh man it's a brutal day isn't it you
know it's funny because you know I'm I'm
dreading tax day because like you know
you've got to set money aside and then
when my accountant comes back and
they're like there's the damage and I'm
just like wow
think about how much stuff we could do
but now I'm gonna give all that money to
the government so I can go blow up kids
and stuff like that and I'm just like
there's a bunch of stuff they do wrong
with our tax dollars but hey how about
that before we get started my friends
let's shout out our sponsor bio trusts
ageless multi-collagen just head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can
pick up your supply of ageless
multi-collagen at 51 off this is the
stuff you need for your joints your
fingernails your skin to be healthy and
young many of you may be saying how is
the Tim look so young but he's 36 years
old why it's in fact actually I have no
idea why but I do love this stuff I put
it in my drinks go to strongerbones in
life.com you'll get a 60-day money-back
guarantee the healthy aging support of
collagen in ideal forms five key types
of collagen you need from four different
sources for every order today to order
today BioTrust will donate a nutritious
meal to a hungry child in your honor
through their partnership with no
kidhungry.org to date BioTrust has
provided over 5 million meals to Hungry
kids please help bio trust their goal of
6 million meals this year it is non-GMO
and free of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners and free of
gluten antibiotics and rbgh and RBST
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth and other collagen supplements no
clumping you get free shipping with
every order free VIP live health and
fitness coaching from BioTrust team of
expert nutrition and health coaches for
life with every order and the free
e-report the 14 foods for amazing skin
with every order thanks so much BioTrust
again stronger bones and life pick it up
if you know look I skate all the time
while skating today and I'm jumping in
the air and Carter was skating he was
falling all over the place it's a good
thing we've got the stuff we can mix
into our drinks help keep our bones
strong but don't forget if you want to
support us directly head over to
timcast.com and become a member in the
top right you can see sign up sign up as
a member you get access to exclusive
members only segments of this show we
will have that members only show coming
up at 11 PM tonight at timcast.com it's
Monday through Thursday but here's the
important thing
all of our journalists they are working
every day to fact check and verify
stories and make sure we're giving you
legitimate up-to-date information real
true stories and we're breaking down the
manipulations from the media we do our
best we're not perfect but we don't sell
these stories we just put them up that
means in order to keep these journalists
employed we rely on membership so
basically what we do is this show we
offer the members only stuff you guys
sign up for that we use those funds to
hire a bunch of journalists to do this
work hopefully for many of you the work
is good enough we have on the ground
reporters like a lot El Yahoo and uh
working on more stuff looking to
expanded documentary so just keep that
in mind too that you know your
membership is keeping all of these
journalists employed and if you think
that that news is important and the way
we we are we are presenting the news and
Reporting the news is important your
membership goes a long way and we
greatly support it share these stories
if you think we're doing a good job of
reporting them now let's jump to the
first big story which is not from
timcast.com it's from The Daily Mail
Biden Administration says TSA will not
enforce masks on planes due to a court
ruling after saki said I'm not a doctor
when asked why face coverings are still
recommended you know I so this this is
it right now uh we have a quote here I
suppose today's Court decision means CDC
public transportation masking order is
not in effect at this time an admin
official said
I don't I don't know what that means if
you're maybe at an airport right now and
you're listening on your headphones
you're about to board your plane and
they're telling you you still got to
wear your mask I honestly have no idea
maybe you can show them this and be like
I'm watching live right now they're
saying I don't got to wear a mask well
that's what the TSA said but these
private Airlines might still want to
enforce masks so we'll see but I just
think it's absolutely hilarious that
we're at this point now where uh during
the White House Press briefing jensaki
is like regardless of the federal court
ruling we're still recommending masks
and and then when Peter Ducey says why
why are you recommending masks if we
don't have to wear masks here in the
White House and her answer was I'm not a
doctor are you a doctor and it's like is
it that's that's the go-to response from
now on right for anything you can also
read it like why are you saying I still
need to wear masks and she's like
because I'm not a doctor and I can yeah
yeah that's gross I have no idea what
I'm talking about that's why yeah
it will be the go-to it will be the
go-to answer for everything every time
something happens in the economy I'm I'm
not an economist I have no idea uh
anytime uh the jobs report under and
like enters up you know lower than
normal like I don't know I'm not a job
recruiter I have no idea why are gas
prices so high are you a petroleum
engineer yeah I'm not a petroleum
engineer
okay yeah I think it points to how
they're all technocrats at heart though
you know like that's like the whole
thing is this this this pivot to
expertise is because they want to
control and manage everything top down
so they're like well I'm not the person
that can manage that top down I'm just
like a part of this technocratic team
and that's not like my position or
whatever but was there like a memo that
went out when katanji Brown Jackson was
asked to find women and she's like I'm
not a biologist and then all of a sudden
some democrat strategy just went oh
that's it and it's like he writes them
up from now on this is what we do I am
not insert specialty
but how do you guys feel about the masks
I mean what is this what does this mean
is this the end of tyranny or is this
like it's a step in the right direction
the United States isn't it's not here
because of of a fake trash Constitution
or country or people we did this for
real to get to this place and this is an
example of the American law working I
think masks personally are disgusting I
don't know if that's what you're asking
about how I feel about masks feeling the
sweat and stick on my face after five
hours on a plane of breathing talking
about recirculated air uh I I just could
never fathom I really understand how
that was should have been better for me
well Ian came upstairs and he was like
masks no more masks I saw I was like
dancing
like teachers letting you go home with
no homework or something yeah that's
what it felt like it really feels like
that and that's silly that's like
they're gaslighting us to feel like that
I think gaslight's the right word
because I shouldn't be celebrating back
to normalcy I should just be expecting
it and ready for it I mean ultimately
you gotta remember this is going to be
enforced by a TSA Employee and those
people are on average uh [ __ ] can I
use that word I don't know I think they
consider it a slur now okay arseners
um like one time mentally deficient okay
there you go I like that it's more it
sounds smarter it's a scientific term
for Behavior though like [ __ ] the word
itself is to mean slow yeah yeah you can
if you don't call people names and stuff
I meant the slur but but real quick I
think mentally deficient is more
offensive yeah yeah yeah like it's
because they're too dumb to get it well
no it's just like you're a certain like
you're trying to make it sound smarter
or like there's something wrong with
them yeah I mean one time I was flying
uh back home from San Jose I was out of
speaking gig and I had a t-shirt on that
had a Grenade on it and this dude at TSA
was like do you think you should be
wearing that to the airport it's like
excuse me he said do you think that's
appropriate and I said do you think you
should be giving me fashion advice like
aren't you supposed to be like looking
at my bag or something
can't say bomb in an airplane GSA is
interesting I'm from the pre-911 era and
there was no TSA it was very felt very
authoritarian and weird when they
created that after 9 11 and then when
you find out there weren't met weapons
of mass destruction in the Middle East
and what the heck is this war on terror
really like why do we still have a TSA I
don't I don't think yeah no you got
grandmas taking their belts off because
we decided to you know invade Iraq or
whatever the funniest thing about the
airport thing is I was flying a lot when
I came out here when I when I moved out
here for work was uh the most uh the
hilarious part was like when you look at
all the signs that you have to wear this
you have to wear that they all had like
sponsored by Purell uh sponsored it was
like it was like is that not the most
like corporatist thing you've ever seen
where it's like all your signs that tell
you you have to do this behave this way
at the airport none of it mentioning
covid uh or anything like that uh at all
I just like to imagine that there's like
some you know the the president of
Purell or whatever companies he's like
he's all his hair is all disheveled and
he's going through the books and he's
like he calls his wife and goes honey
we're not gonna have Christmas dinner
sales are just really bad and then he
looks at the TV and it's like coveted
lockdown he goes oh and then and then he
throws the papers in there and he opens
when he goes get your work boys we're
back in business yeah now he's like
super rich and he's got to Scrooge
McDuck that was one of the memes that
says the the Creator or the owner of
Purell right now it's got like nine gold
chains on and a bunch in a ring on each
finger it's like that's exactly what it
is them in the whoever invented the man
whoever's like producing The Masks China
China wasn't the my pillow guy making
mass and they still hate him oh yeah
yeah that's right yeah he shifted
production to start making masks yeah
and they were like masterbat now we're
not we can't support anything he's doing
that was that because I'm from Minnesota
and it was really funny like people from
Minnesota just hated that guy uh for for
no reason they have no idea why they
just they've just been told that they
have to hate him so so we we got to pull
up this tweet it was a great tweet and
you know let me just preface this by
saying I don't I don't normally care to
you know mock people who are just not
relevant but this woman is apparently an
elected representative an elected
official this woman uh Lindsay sabadosa
says today a federal judge called it
overreach for U.S health officials to
require masks on airplanes and other
public transmit Transit and no matter
how you feel about masks you should you
should be really really concerned that
the courts are effectively taking away
power from the federal government should
we know okay
okay hold on there a minute it was a
federal judge who issued a ruling on a
federal mandate
this is more of an uh I guess if you
think that the courts are taking apart
with the power from federal government
if if she's discussing some kind of like
oroboros you know the snake eating
that's eating itself yeah maybe uh but I
think she just has no idea I think she
means taking power away from the
executive branch as it was intended and
that's where we have the separation of
powers for don't be charitable Ian
that's my that's my job like this is
this is the thing that I think we often
do is Joe Biden will do something and
we'll be like well maybe he really meant
this and oh I I fully agree this is a
foolish and irrational treat it treat it
doesn't make any sense and she's all
sorts of names no no I don't know but
that's a that's a dumb tweet that is
wrong the Court's job is to strip away
power from the Executive Branch if it
goes too far progress well it's to
interpret the law uh Progressive
Democrat and state representative first
Hampshire District I believe it's in
Massachusetts that's correct and it's
just oh oh my stars and Gardens I looked
her up and she's also before she's a
politician it says she's an activist and
I was like yeah that checks out well
look look I want to say I mean no ill
will towards this this this woman she
said nothing mean to me
um she just was
Jesus doesn't know what she's talking
about and so the first thing I would
like to do is just say
um hey you were wrong you should you
should fix that uh I don't I don't want
to rag on her for being you know
incorrect about this or not
understanding how the government works
but I'll I will I will say while we try
to be nice and respectful because she
has not you know maybe maybe she's
talked about me in the past I have no
idea but if she's being if she said
nothing mean to me I want to be mean to
her I would just say I have serious
questions about her uh her ability to
work in government if she doesn't
understand what courts federal courts
are and what they do
that is a more professional critique
right yeah trying to keep things
respectful I guess isn't the whole
Progressive claim that they're for the
people and power of the people and all
this and everything they tweet or say or
whatever is all about the power of the
government no I got to stop you I don't
I think progressives are are
authoritarian and they've I'm pretty
sure they've always been now I agree
with that but I don't think they claimed
it before the people oh I see yeah yeah
some of them may because it's probably
you know from authoritarian to
libertarian to a certain degree but
typically Progressive just refers to you
know uh doing what you we think is right
for the sake of progress so these are
people who in the past were eugenicists
I don't think the Progressive Movement
has ever been particularly we want to
protect all the people it's more like
how do we control the system better you
know yeah and maybe I'm making a mistake
of using like AOC as the Avatar of
progressivism because like with her
she's just always talking about the
people you know the people the people
the people but in you know in
practicality or you know in reality it's
always about more power consumption well
yeah like you know I mean tankies like
you know Communists and stuff they're
saying we're going to help the people by
force and that's that's like that's you
know kind of like AOC I'm surprised
people still defend her it's remarkable
the there was that that guy what's his
name Chris I think his name is the union
guy in New York who started the he
started a union at the Amazon Factory
they fired him and then he started the
union very successful Tucker Carlson had
him on and you know he's he he's he's
busted his ass to get this done to push
back against one of the most I think
Amazon is evil terrible company but
we're all addicted to it and uh aoc's
nowhere to be found and then when he
when he wins when when the when the
warehouse votes to unionize aoc's all
tweeting like yeah we did it and he's
just like what where have you been Chris
Smalls is his name yeah yeah yeah
Amazon uh Russell Brand just had a video
that came out yesterday about like
Amazon has like an internal messaging
service in there and they're like
censoring words like you can't say sir
certain phrases like Union or bathroom
break and it's just like is that not the
most authoritarian thing ever now it's
like they want to like reward you by
having like like kind of like how you
have like likes on Instagram and stuff
like that so it's like you don't want to
get a raise you want to get your
co-workers to give you likes on your
internal messaging service app for your
for your company that doesn't let you
talk about bathroom breaks and doesn't
allow you to uh to unionize because uh
but what did they say they spent 93
million dollars on anti-union uh
lobbyists or something in the same year
yeah I'm looking at theverge.com some of
the words that Amazon's banned with that
App Master Slave Injustice ethics
some of them are really funny some of
them are yeah you can't say diversity
unfairly yeah holy cow well okay it's
all right then that's weird yeah yeah
yeah yeah no also I love Bezos
all right well let's uh let's rag on
jensaki a little bit Yeah so we have the
story from the Independent saki says is
her name Saki is it Saki Bomb says Peter
Ducey sounds like a stupid son of uh B
yeah wouldn't you keep it family
friendly because of Fox's questions
Biden caught on hot Mike in January
calling Ducey a stupid SOB over
inflation question and then saki just
comes out and says it I just want to
point out
um
I was watching Peter Ducey question Jen
at the White House Press briefing today
and I was offended at how bad she was at
this because I've praised her in the
past as being a good spin doctor because
you know Biden will do something just
horrifyingly bad or he'll just like fall
asleep in public or something I'm
kidding by the way but he'll and she'll
find a way to spin it and I'm like yeah
she's good I mean she's doing what she
does but today it was just like wow and
you know really well let me let me
explain yeah she was asked Peter Ducey
why do you recommend masks when we don't
have to and her response was I'm not a
doctor are you a doctor you're not a
doctor I'm not a doctor and I'm like Jen
like wow this one's really easy you just
say airplanes are smaller with
recirculated air yeah I was like you
couldn't even just say that to Peter
Ducey was like wow she was not good at
this there were a couple other things
that came out and she was bad but the
interesting thing here I suppose is that
she's she's reportedly going to MSNBC so
here she is it's it's during a taping of
pod save America oh yeah she was asked
if Mr Ducey was a stupid SOB or if he
just acted like one on TV she said he
works for a network that provides people
with questions that nothing personal to
any individual including Ducey but might
make anyone sound like a stupid SOB
that's really amazing that the only real
questions that come out of that briefing
okay it's not fair but ninety percent of
the real questions come from Peter Ducey
there there were um
there was one guy I saw asking some good
questions but I'm sitting there watching
this briefing and I'm just like has
there ever been a point in our lifetimes
where the White House Press briefing
revealed any relevant or important
information or are we all just
recognizing it's a it's a it's theater
and and the the whether it be Sean spice
or gen saki they're going to say
whatever they have to to spin they're
not going to tell you the truth for once
I'd like someone to come out with like a
scotch and it's like you know just
Donald Trump or Biden and he's like
swirling it and they're like what are we
doing in Yemen making a lot of money
we're selling weapons to the Saudis in
known and they're blowing up Villages
but good for the economy next question
Syria oh oil well we're trying to build
the pipeline what's next and I'm just
like wow you know but they're not going
to do that I would love to see inside of
Kaylee McInerney's big book that she
used to carry with her I would love to
see what's in there okay I gotta take
that back yes she's great that was epic
she had the big book and whenever the
Press would say something she'd be like
hmm and she'd like friends you're full
of it okay that was actually substantive
yeah that maybe wasn't giving us real
answers about the administration but it
was exposing to the American people how
the media was totally full of it yeah
when this girl when we talk about how
she uh is good I think that's come up in
the past that she's good at her job I'm
like well you can be good at your job
and be evil if your job is evil like
Joseph Goebbels Hitler's minister of
propaganda was good but so instead of
using the word good say effective say he
did it don't say he was good say he was
he was effective at his job which was
evil and so is jensaki sometimes if
she's lying to people that's evil you
could say she's doing a public good by
lying to people because some of the the
information is too dangerous if the CIA
is a secretive organization on purpose
but I don't think that's I don't know
what do you think about it if there is
any man on the planet who is the easiest
to take out of context and make a
montage of just horrifying things in him
yes thank you Tim you recognize my
greatness
I have my own no no but the the issue is
you know when Ian made a good point just
now that uh gerbils yeah Joseph Joseph
Goebbels or something he was effective
and it was terrifying but when you say
that when he was good at his job and he
was evil said he was good yeah but what
kind of got stopped diverted I'm like
you got to make sure you finish that
clean up he was effective so were the
Nazis of what they were trying to
accomplish but they weren't good and so
that's so you can look at what Jen's
doing I mean she's now she's just bad at
her job and also doing I don't know if I
want to claim she's doing evil but I
want to I want to have hope for the
American government but sometimes I
think like a little transparency goes a
long way yo they're checked out I think
they're all evil I mean they've been put
forcing Mass on little kids in airplanes
you know kicking families off because a
two-year-old won't wear their mask you
know uh child suicide rates are through
the roof right now drug addictions up
through the roof everyone who pushes
this is evil I'm totally fine with using
that word uh they're good at being
people I guess are effective at being
evil I agree and I want to elaborate on
that when you have a machine that says
two-year-olds must wear masks yeah and
we're like okay we get it but then you
get these videos like even people
willing to be like we want to do we want
to be peaceful we don't want
confrontation you get these videos where
the baby they put the mask on the baby
and the baby takes it off at like
literal baby and then they're like off
the plane and I'm like dude when you
have become this machine that doesn't
care about people you have become evil
and I've talked about it before I can't
stand what has become of the U.S court
system
it's been this way to varying degrees
but it's getting worse in that
I get pulled over once I wasn't speeding
cop walks up to me with a ticket and he
says sign there and I was like I wasn't
speeding because I don't care talk to a
judge and I was like now I gotta take
off work to go to a judge I go to the
judge he goes I don't care cop said you
were speeding pay the fine or you know
fight it and I'm like
okay you know we've become extremely
rigid because we don't know or care
about each other and this is one of the
big challenges the way we use what you
know in this country is founded we had
two million people you wouldn't have
police you had local militia so if
somebody stole something it's like round
up the boys we're gonna go we're gonna
go catch that guy who stole something
and then you'd have to go to the courts
and the courts were part of the
community everybody knew each other and
they'd all talk it out and it's like
that guy who stole it that's that's
that's you know John's son and it's like
oh man John what do you got to say for
your kid and then they talk about it now
it's like I don't know this guy I don't
even know his name is now there's so
many people and it's so dense we've just
become rigid and mechanized almost I see
ups and downs to both because if you
know the judge and then you commit a
crime and the judge is like I know I'm
just let him off that's also bad but if
you the judge has no idea who you are
and they don't take your Humanity into
account at all then that's also kind of
bad I agree but I I think of it like
they still exists in small town America
where uh if you live in a small town and
you're speeding let's say a 16 17 year
old kid speeding and the the deputy
pulls him over he already knows who it
is so he's not worried about getting
shot or anything and he walks up and
he's like Jimmy why speeding and he's
like I'm sorry Dan and he's like I'm
gonna see your dad at the bar later
today and I'm gonna tell him your speed
and he's like please don't and he's like
I'm much out for the warning but I'm
telling your dad like that's way more
effective social uh repercussions as
opposed to like pay the 35 bucks or pay
the 50 bucks for a lot of people that 50
bucks is devastating but they're like I
don't care you know so what I'll I'll
not pay the ticket or I'll fight it or
whatever having that personal connection
I think is good because it holds people
to account because they're scared of
people they know and love getting mad at
him I think you're right about that and
there's also just that there's two darn
many laws oh no so we've got so many
people going through the system all the
time it almost has to be a mechanical
and expedited you really can't add the
human element in if you've got It's
let's say you're a judge and you've got
a judge on 50 cases in a day or whatever
how serious can you take the individual
in each of those I mean there's only so
many minutes in a day yeah they're
they're gonna especially not even just
judges but prosecutors they're only
going to see you as a number or as a way
to advance their career and it's almost
not even like I'd like to say it's on
them but a career-oriented person who
goes into a field like that they're
going to be predisposed to looking at
people that way and that's just how they
uh they've chosen to get ahead with
their career they've just happened to
take a career that puts other people's
lives in you know in the balance each
and every day yeah then you have to ask
yourself why they chose that job that's
a whole nother discussion they're
they're I pulled up just like weird laws
but one of them is like bingo games
can't last more than five hours in North
Carolina you can't sniff glue with the
intent to get high from it in Indiana
can't have sex with living fish in
Minnesota okay they might actually
support that one yeah yeah that's not a
weird law that's a good one the word
living
it's uh those there was like a song
where they referenced that and I was
like that can't be real can it and then
I I don't know if that's they've since
uh repealed that just to say any fish
perhaps but yes that was uh that was a
thing this is a great metaphor talking
about the machine we were talking last
night about how machines are very
dangerous and we've kind of become
enslaved to them they're very
intelligent and we can build their
intelligence but they have no emotion
humans have emotion that's why we
enslave the machine to work for us and
to Outsource our intelligence at what
level does a society become a machine
like a small town it's all about emotion
who you know your kids their kids then
all of a sudden at some point it's like
just fill out the paperwork you don't
even have to look at the guy's face like
what 60 000 people 20 106 1600 people
yeah remember that movie Office uh what
was it office space yeah and they take
the printer out and beat the tar out of
it or whatever you are the printer oh
that's the tech that's the technocratic
dream yeah I mean well I mean I just
think that uh the
fundamentally that movie is about being
caught up in a Mindless numbing job
that's functioning a lot like a
bureaucracy and every level of justice
system is a Mindless numbing bureaucracy
so when you go in there you're the
printer man and printers are still
worthy of that like we have a printer
here that's they're all awful like it's
the only technology that hasn't expanded
at all every printer is still a hassle
to use all the time did you guys ever
have that black printer ink explode on
you when you're trying to change it it's
so crazy it's like there's like a rule
against making them better they're like
it has to be a hassle and it's just
nobody wants to nobody wants to create a
better printer I agree yeah maybe lasers
maybe we can just have lasers do a back
image on a paper it's probably created
yo let's talk about Alex Jones oh yeah
we got the story from timcast.com update
Alex Jones disputes widespread claims
that Infowars is filing bankruptcy quote
we are filing a chapter 11
reorganization so that the federal
government can come in and look at our
books Jones said now that you gotta love
technically the truth the best kind of
the truth the truth is Alex Jones did
file for chapter 11 which is under
bankruptcy laws I suppose the fair way
to phrase it is that he's disputing the
idea that they're broke he says quote I
am not filing bankruptcy Infowars is not
filing bankruptcy we are filing a
chapter 11 reorganization so that the
federal government can come in and look
at our books to see that we do not have
16 million dollars in a secret bank
account we do not have five million
dollars even we have about three million
dollars that is that is necessary in
order to operate
we are what the mainstream media truly
fears honest independent media said
Jones this filing is strategic to allow
me to pay my creditors and remain
transparent
that is a form of bankruptcy I think
however the media is trying to frame it
like they're broke and destitute and
most people think bankruptcy means
you're out of money I'll give you an
example I searched chapter 11 bankruptcy
and one of the first news articles came
up from NBC Alex Jones Infowars files
for chapter 11 bankruptcy protection
it's formed protection then I click on
the article the title's been changed
Alex Jones's Infowars files for
bankruptcy following Sandy Hook lawsuits
so it's like they printed the article as
it was really happening and then they're
like not scandalous enough let's make
them look bad bring up Sandy Hook let's
get them no they want it they wanted
Buzz terms so that it would get more
clicks that's what they do and uh
there's something they do at news
organizations media Outlets called a b
testing where they actually this is
fascinating they can publish an article
with multiple headlines in different
regions to see which one does better in
real time and then switch it all out not
only that but a headline newspapers do
this too this is a crazy thing you look
at like New York Times I don't know if
the New York Times does it but you'll
look at like the California edition
versus the Texas edition versus the Utah
Edition and they'll use different
headlines to sell papers because they
know I think Time Magazine actually made
a different person of the year for
different countries I think at some
point you guys remember that oh I don't
know I'll look into that as we're
talking and that's why they don't like
Alex Jones I'm gonna be honest if he is
going bankrupt I get it because
everything he talked about for like the
last 20 years happened so he's just like
nothing to ramble about because people
were like yeah man we do have that drive
people really are you know the frogs
really are well so the the frogs thing
was funny I was on uh first let me just
say when it comes to Alex he he reads
the news a lot and then he talks all
about this and sometimes he'll find
something and take it in the wrong
direction so that's why when he gets
things right we don't like we don't
believe it we're like there's no way
that's true like when he was here and he
was like reading cloned beef and I was
like no we're not it's like Google it
and I did and it's like we're actually
eating okay wow I didn't believe him so
there's a lot of crazy things you think
are are you know are crazy turns out he
was right but I will say he's absolutely
wrong to talk about Sandy Hook the way
he did and this is I I would say look if
you defame someone you could help to
account when the big media companies
went after the Covington kids well they
get they get sued and they're going to
pay out their settlement good Alex Jones
should not have been talking about
private individuals making accusations
about them like this he did not have the
proof to make these claims yeah and I
look at Alex Jones as like a pro
wrestling of media just pure
entertainment you know like I find him
entertaining and fun I mean I don't like
watch a show but I watch pretty much
whenever he goes on something like your
show or Rogan or something
um so I can see how he could slip into
this but you're totally right especially
once you start going after the parents
of a dead child you kind of deserve what
you get at that point yep yep he's been
pretty transparent about that he was
wrong that's something if he if he's
still holding on like oh no no no then
I'd be like you know what I don't even
want this guy but the fact that he's
open and like yeah I screwed up big time
and he's paying his dues that's the
first step so look he said he was wrong
he apologized he offered to settle 120k
to each of the families and they said
something like he's TR the settlement
offer was an attempt to avoid his public
Reckoning and I'm like is that what this
is about because if he already admitted
he's wrong and apologized and then
offered to pay you out I think you've
won yeah like what what do you want well
they want a purple walk they want a
public you know uh event and I'm like I
don't know I kind of feel like CNN
settled and I'm satisfied like I don't
like seeing I'm never gonna like them
but they they lose they go to the coming
to kids they're like we lose when that
happened we're all like yeah like there
we go we move on best thing that came
out of this is that he uses research now
when now when he's working he has like
16 papers at him when he comes on the
show he has a bunch of documents ready
to go he doesn't stray off his topic he
does well his research unless you want
to have fun with him but he came here
and he's like I got all the I got all
the research the proof and he hands it
to me and it was just Infowars yeah I
was like dude this is you you know I
went to Sandy Hooks I actually went up
there that day I was in Connecticut
working with mines and the shooting
happened and they were like you want to
go cover this so I was like yeah I guess
so I don't you know so I drove up there
and uh man it was somber this is all
anecdotal it doesn't prove or
disproviving obviously it was a real
thing at this point but I tried to
interview people no one wanted to talk
well they had the media across the
street you could see the fire trucks I
mean it was really really good why does
anyone want to talk about that yeah we
just uh we did a story the other day
covering like a documentary filmmaker
who's covering AstroWorld the the
tragedy at AstroWorld and how he's like
he's like I am a victim driven uh
documentary filmmaker who goes around
and covers uh various tragedies like
this and like one of the issues that the
dude has is that he has to go and he
tries to get interviews with people and
a lot of times he'll push really heavily
with these victims families to try and
get them to talk on record and that
comes off you know some might want to
have that discussion but other ones have
no interest in it and you know a good
documentary filmmaker unfortunately
given you know what he chose for a
profession is going to have to push back
if he wants to get the story but he's
just not taking a cue from the fact that
he's using such heavy material to do
that and that could be seen as something
like this here so so I want to I want to
dig into this uh Infowars Claim about
this hidden money right so Alex is
saying the the reorganization is so that
the feds can see they don't have 16
million dollars in a secret bank account
I don't know if that's what's being
argued there be uh he's there's a new
lawsuit and maybe I'm wrong let me see
if we can pull this up
a newly filed lawsuit alleges that uh
let me read this they say after Alex
Jones was sued for claiming the you know
what he did about Sandy Hook
the uh conspiracy theorists conspired to
diver that's fine conspired to divert
his assets to Shell companies owned by
insiders like his parents his children
and himself reads the lawsuit which was
filed in Austin Texas by some of the
families so they're not saying he has a
secret bank account they're saying that
he immediately started doing deals
funneling this money away I don't know
how you win a lawsuit like that to be
completely honest because like you know
you can sue somebody but if they haven't
lost or owe you anything they can spend
the money however they want you don't
get to just say you're not allowed to
spend money anymore because I'm suing
you imagine if that's how things worked
it's like I don't want Disney to make a
movie so I'll assume and now they can't
spend any money no that's ridiculous
they started the process of going after
Alex maybe at that point he said all
right you know I'm gonna do a bunch of
deals to pull all this money out of the
company and that way it'll be with
people I know and I can file bankruptcy
maybe but what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do you didn't win the lawsuit
then they do how much money does he have
well there you go now and going forward
in the future he's gonna have to pay you
back but that money's gone so Infowars
is getting sued not Alex Jones is that
right I don't know for sure exactly how
they structured the lawsuit I know that
three companies that uh IW Health prison
planet and Infowars have filed for
chapter 11. that's what's been reported
okay so I think they may be going after
him and his companies or something it's
really interesting how this stuff works
out so uh you know typically I think
people have been suing the individuals
and the businesses wow yeah so when
journalists do things like you know the
reporters on the line and the companies
on the line for publishing it
makes sense
yeah so the reporter isn't allowed
protections I I'm just curious about
that the reporter isn't allowed
protections just because they're working
for the the company they're still
responsible in addition to the okay
you're the one who said it and the
company is the one who Amplified it so
now
but you know what man you can sue a ham
sandwich doesn't mean you're going to
win we'll see how this plays out I
suppose The Narrative is that the
lawsuit is
to to silence a prominent influential
person on the right and that's why
they're not they're not satisfied with
the settlement offer yeah they don't
want the settlement offer they want him
to come out as the bad guy like you said
purple walk they want to they want
humiliation they want him to look bad
not just pay out for what he did and
that's the difference between actually
wanting Justice uh and actually wanting
someone to pay and I think those aren't
necessarily always the same thing I I
wonder though at this point you know
Alex has said that they submitted their
documents and the courts were like nope
you didn't give us your documents and
he's like what do you mean I gave you
everything I'm like no you didn't and
he's like but we did and I actually uh
talked with him and his lawyer and his
lawyer was like we gave them everything
they are just saying we didn't and they
put us in default and it's like what do
we give them if we don't have anything
else to give them it's like it's like
when you're being interrogated by
someone like tell us where the gold is
like I don't know yes you do and they're
beating you like what do you do if you
don't know just lie I guess so they're
saying they got nothing left to give but
they're being you know put in default so
they can't what are they supposed to do
at this point wasn't there a conspiracy
theory for a long time that Alex Jones
was actually a CIA asset and that he was
being used there's always that
conspiracy theory so at least we can put
that to bed yeah
or it's just a you know they're trying
to pull them out clever yeah now it's
like we got to get Alex out of there man
and so like here's how we're gonna do it
and you know Alex is like I'm quitting I
was on I like the idea that like him
being reassigned by the CIA to like like
the Reykjavik like a foreign country uh
like a station Chief and some uh like
really far away place because they can't
use them here anymore
I
I kind of feel like there's there's
powerful interests at play in a lot of
these suits that we've been seeing it
started with you know Gawker right Peter
Thiel funds this lawsuit against Gawker
and blows it up that was the Hulk Hogan
one yeah
and now it's like this is this this is
law fair it's how it works I'm kind of
just like Alex Jones is Alex Jones
everything else doesn't matter he could
do his show on a cell phone he could be
like okay you know what fine
shut her down start a new company and
then just talk into a camera what are
they going to do how much do you think I
mean you're in a position to answer this
how much do you think being removed from
Twitter and YouTube and those other
platforms is affecting his business I
think it probably knocked him down you
know the majority of the money he was
making
but I guess people should understand
Alex Jones got started on I think Public
Access TV and then he made internet
video documentaries and he I think he
saw I think he was selling them all I
know people were sharing them for free
and then he launched his website before
YouTube and social media existed he was
he was well off and running this big
company then you get YouTube you get
Twitter you get Facebook and he gets
even bigger he loses all of that he's
back he's actually still doing better
than he was before social media because
he created band.video he's got his own
video player now he gets hundreds of
thousands of views still people like you
can't take away that level of Fame from
somebody
so that's why I'm saying even if they
destroyed all of his companies all he's
got to do is strap strap on a loincloth
and go in the woods with a cell phone
and people are going to want to watch it
I would subscribe to that by the way
there yes
Alex Jones jungle man I'm surviving
today people this is how you live with
it it's on your back
I mean actually would be a really great
show incredible incredible Alex let's do
a documentary that would be incredible
Alex Jones or a short film or something
you know now with the the Twitter stuff
is interesting because it looks like
what's you know Elon Musk trying to buy
Twitter it's just powerful interest
trying to
block
people who are challenging the system or
these conversations it just looks like
there's evil power at play trying to
control manipulate
people have been talking about parallel
systems for a long time parallel
economies and all this and this move
with Elon Musk and there's been some
speculation that maybe Peter till will
get involved in some other of elon's
friends billionaire like sort of
investors would get involved to me it's
the first step in an actual uh like a
sort of a parallel Cathedral element you
know or a competing uh Cathedral element
you know to attack the actual system
that it sort of is feels oppressive as
the every man so I'm kind of like Ford I
know some people have been like well
you're just cheering on you know your
own right-wing Caesar type character
whatever not my first of all I don't
think the guy's right winning at all but
second of all yeah for sure I totally am
you know like I will take anybody who
wants to win at this point I get I get
kind of like I I see the pushback he's
getting okay so there's a couple ways to
go at it you can try and reverse
engineer the software get a bunch of
developers together that want to work on
like a free software system and try and
rebuild what's already been built which
takes forever and so many hours of labor
for development labor or you can come
from the top buy the organization and
then free the software code that way but
we see with Elon it's like the Saudi
Prince is is tweeting out he doesn't
want to let go of his his power these
people BlackRock I think or is it
Vanguard I think vanguard's in kind of
hard they don't want to give up so it's
it's challenging to take it from the top
when you're using their money the Fiat
because they control the Fiat and I say
they it's so vague but it's the Federal
Reserve and these giant mega Corps that
get first dibs on all the money when
they loan it out you wanna you wanna you
wanna make a guess Ian as to who is the
largest Institutional Investor in Tesla
oh I saw you tweeted out earlier so I
can't but what about you Brett uh I I
think we talked about it earlier sorry
how do you guys think put in the super
chats you'll find out I just said it's
Vanguard Vanguard Vanguard then uh
Capital something then I think BlackRock
and then I think it's State Street
Global advisors I swear you this is the
problem with going public man you can't
stop it once you once you get in that
pool the big fish come and that's that
that's
I really do love how BlackRock is just a
really really like uh evil Corporation
sounding name it's my favorite part
about it it's like uh what was the other
one we were talking about earlier black
black water
no for the the private uh private
mercenary group from those black water
yeah they changed their names but I love
it's just so uh evil super villain
sounding it's great let's talk about
DeSantis and see where we're uh where
we're heading this country
textbook rejection as Dems seek proof of
critical race Theory lessons Florida
Education Department officials have not
yet provided examples from the textbook
textbooks deemed impermiss impermissible
but on Monday released the list of books
that failed to make the cut so
apparently
understand this defended it we want kids
to learn to think so they get the right
answer to Santa's told reporters the
Florida Department of Education on
Friday rejected some 54 math books from
State classrooms a move that Drew
national attention when Santa's claimed
the proposals from publishing companies
contain lessons on indoctrinating
Concepts like race essentialism
the move was just the latest example of
Republicans including DeSantis
scrutinizing what students are learning
blah blah okay here's the question
if the math books don't have critical
race theory in them why are they bent
out of shape they're getting removed if
it's just a math book where it's like
two plus two is four then why why would
they be mad about that they'd be like oh
I guess do we still have a math book
that says two plus two equals four then
why do we care if he removed that one
this is really interesting because
because it is possible that they're not
actually teaching critical race Theory
and what they're doing is teaching a
form of Praxis which is where critical
theory isn't everything it doesn't have
to be explicit it underlies everything
I've seen some of these math problems I
think it was Matt Walsh earlier today
who was reading some of these questions
about Maya Angelou and all the stuff
that went in on her life all this racism
she stood up to it's a math problem
you're supposed to be solving X and Y
and a and b and all this stuff but
they're rolling into it all these ideas
so that they can say we're not teaching
critical race Theory this is practice
we've talked about this before this is
critical race applied right so an
example would be those old math problems
where it's like a train leaves Detroit
traveling 500 miles an hour and a train
leaves Pittsburgh traveling at 50 miles
an hour and blah blah blah and then um
you know that's a math problem what
they're doing in these is they're like
Johnny is a young white man who's 15
years 15 years old and he gets stopped
by the police three times in one month
but Jerome is a young black man who gets
stopped by the police two thousand times
in one month what percentage of stops
were and then you're like okay we get it
that's what they're doing yeah I
honestly think it if anything it doesn't
go far enough I we as far as desantises
move here uh I had to go pick up one of
my kids from I have one kid in public
school and the rest of mine are
homeschooled but uh I had to go pick her
up
and there was a a class the kids must
have been maybe seven years old and all
across the wall is the you know rainbow
flags and uh trans flag now nothing said
you know anything about but but the
coloring is all the right coloring you
know and there's like little sneaky
words you know like sharing is caring
like Care Bears type stuff and this is
in a Tiny Town in in Idaho in the
mountains of Idaho I mean tiny that's so
it's everywhere and it's it's like being
pumped into these kids brains I actually
think like that's why colors are so
important there's no kids like latch on
to that stuff and it's very visually
appealing for them so when it's
broadcast in their faces all the time
you don't have to have an explicit
message in there the messages like in
the image I still remember an image like
in fourth grade on my wall of the of a
horn like a trumpet playing music and it
showed the sound waves coming out like
this like round sorry if you're
listening you're not able to see but
then then the teacher came in one day I
was like actually the sound waves are
actually like this and they changed the
image of to a sine wave and that was
that sticks with me today that was like
35 years ago or something crazy imagery
is the most one of the most powerful
ways to teach a child anything sound
imagery smell those kind of things yeah
sensory stuff there are a bunch of these
videos that are coming out and it's
starting to expose to these people we're
doing one of them is the um like a
gender flow chart almost yeah and
there's it's from Libs of tick tock I
saw this
where the teacher is like you start with
your your sexuality and then you can go
as far as you want towards male or
female and then you come down to your
identity and it can be different and
it's like it's not
the thing is if you tell a kid
trans people exist
gay people exist it's like okay I get it
you're telling them they exist if you
give them a card and tell them to draw
on a scale where they are now you're
you're actually not just telling them
exist now you're doing some kind of
litmus test for them and their identity
and what happens then
if these kids feel like they're not
going to fit in if they go with the
Bland gray flag the the Siz flag they've
been showing kids is just black and
white so why would a kid pick that one
why would the kid want to be the you
know boring no you can be fun and
exciting here do these things and so
these kids don't understand oppression
they don't understand civil rights these
are young kids between you know five
years old and nine years old they're
being told just to draw how they feel
and they're like whatever
the only thing they're going after them
for because at that age they don't
understand sexuality at all they don't
have you know they're not they're
prepubescent and all this so if you go
after them then and you like start
talking to them about sexual orientation
of course like Johnny and Jack are going
to say that they like each other more
because girls are stupid and icky or
whatever so then when they do start to
develop actual hormones and feelings
you're just like adding layers of
confusion because now they're getting
all the you know testosterone's flowing
they're like well I thought I liked you
know jack it turns out maybe chill's all
right you know I've heard some horror
stories from these are coming out of
conservative states where like someone's
kid said that they thought they were pan
and their parent was like why do you
think you're pan and they're like
because I like everybody and they're
like you you like everybody that means
you want to kiss them and and their
daughter was like No And they're only
yeah I just mean like I want to be
friends with them and they're like
that's not what that means they're lying
to those kids I'm not saying it's every
classroom but certainly that is
happening because these kids don't know
what that means and there's no way it
gets to that level of teaching that they
don't know that they're confusing them
and that's the worst part about it is
that it's being obfuscated intentionally
uh partially because they know the kids
aren't old enough to really process what
that means and partially just everything
that you don't say is everything ever is
every bit as important as what you
choose to say and what you leave out
says almost more about it than what you
put in and that's that's terrifying to
me yeah well I think it's I I think
reality is yeah these teachers aren't
documenting kids and then the media is
doing everything in its power to push
back so Eber Mexican D recently came out
and said that uh oh no they're grooming
kids to be white supremacists and it's
like wow it's working if he's got to
come out and try and do that the
messaging has worked you've got candy
trying to retake the word groomer
because they're grooming kids it ain't
gonna work buddy no did you cover the
the first grade teacher who like told
like told the first grade class that
when when babies are born that they just
get the doctor just guesses whether it's
a boy or a girl oh yeah I think we
talked about that talk about that I
don't remember that they just guessed
that they just told me because doctors
guesses that's what happens there's
another video from Libs of tick tock
where the doctor's basically saying that
where it's like it's typically based on
their their you know their their
genetics and their genitals but usually
it's just their genitals and sometimes
they're wrong it's like
well sometimes as in like you know point
zero seven zero zero yeah percent of the
time yeah but that's why ethics is so
important science can only get you so
far you can only you can only look at
pieces and parts and decide your final
answer but I mean and that's I think
maybe that the conversation about ethics
and emotions has gone kind of too far in
One Direction where it's like if you
feel like you're different sex then then
that's reality because we have not been
having much talk about emotions so this
is like the the Hammers coming swinging
back I feel like society's really
detached from its Emotional Self how
often do you see people cry how often do
you see people publicly acknowledging
their suffering
well I mean you could kids that used to
have even though they weren't living on
a farm or whatever they used to know
people that were farmers they had a
grandfather that was a farmer or you
know an uncle or whatever and so they
were involved with animal husbandry and
that stuff at a younger age and you
don't have to explain like kids Ranch
kids don't get birds and the bees talks
because they've been breeding animals
you know being they've been around
animals who were being bred since they
were very very young so there's an
implicit understanding there like Dad
doesn't have to sit down and say you
know when a mama bee loves a daddy bee
you know it's like they've been seeing
stud horses and mares out in the pasture
chickens chickens yeah yeah like we got
we got chicken City and I was thinking
about this too um a lot of people talk
about how their kids will watch chicken
City their dogs and their cats obviously
watch it too but chicken cities become
this massive success thank you everybody
but no in all seriousness the uh you
know you'll get kids watching with their
parents and they'll be like I want to
feed the chickens and so they'll put the
five bucks in the food comes down
and then you'll see the rooster Mount
the hen and you know do his rooster
business explain that well I mean it's
this this chicken city is overtly over
the top family friendly chickens do
these things like if you want to teach
your kids about farms and pettings
you're going to watch that stuff happen
sure now maybe if your kid's never been
exposed to that you're gonna have to
have that conversation but to your point
that I was thinking about this earlier I
was like
kid who grows up on a goat farm is never
going to have that question because
they're like a little kid watching the
goats do their thing you know what I
mean yeah it's it's just totally true
and the chicken thing might be a little
bit hard because then it's like wait so
we're eating chicken babies that's
worried
oh wow yeah yup every day those eggs
come out it's not necessarily a baby
yeah right but uh you don't eat the
chicks you got away from the grow that's
where you get the meat do you guys have
a farm yeah do you did you explain to
your kids about like we're raising the
animals we're gonna eat the animals or
anything like that oh I mean no I don't
know it just kind of happens my in fact
my little sister when she was she was
probably 10 years old or so maybe now
she was younger than that seven or eight
years old anyway she'd come come home
from school and got off the school bus
and I was out feeding her something and
I came around and she and uh I just come
in the back door and I hear you hey Mom
I'm hungry I want to eat Bob
it was this it was this steer that she'd
named Bob you know and she loved the
steer or whatever but she's like
whatever's food food like he's cute and
everything but we're gonna eat him so I
not not as it's another one of those
things just kind of implicit I don't
think imagine being Bob yeah right yeah
I know that name do they do they like
argue against naming them for that
reason uh no I'm I mean uh my stepfather
used to hate it but I like for me
personally it doesn't bother me at all
like yesterday I was at my in-laws uh
getting ready to come well Easter and
then getting ready to come out here and
as soon as I left we had a one of our
heifers calved you know my wife comes
home she's like oh look at this so cute
you know like I mean thank goodness I
didn't have to pull it or anything but
you know she's talking about how cute
these little Angus calves are or
whatever and I'm like yeah I get it and
then you know the kids are hearing her
talk like that but they never
they never have a problem you know
eating like they know it's a cow that's
what you're raised from the beginning
with that you would just know from the
tiniest age yeah I think you're just
closer to it or something this is this
is interesting because we we have asked
many times like who would who it's going
to survive better in the apocalypse or
who is more likely to survive a
conservative role or Urban liberal and a
lot it's like no one thinks the urban
Liberals are going to make it but this
is a really good point we don't we we've
not brought up it's that people who grow
up in rural areas are more likely to
have been exposed at a young age to
slaughtering a pig or a chicken to eat
like you know I want to eat Bob
people in the city are going to be like
I have to do what with the knife and
then what do I do with those things yeah
they're not going to want to do it they
want to walk into a supermarket where
there's just pink slime
they can just you know cook it and eat
it we had a farm my debt my
grandfather's Grandpa's cousin had a
farm Northeast Ohio and we would go out
there Alvin Uncle Alvin and cousin Alvin
and then we see the the thing hanging
upside down like the cattle thing just
the all the blood all the skin ripped
off and it's like wow wow and they I
don't think I ever watched them butcher
it up and I never saw him kill it I did
see my dad kill some kill a groundhog
and that was well he he family friendly
he wounded the groundhog and it escaped
and I just saw the trail of blood and it
was really disturbing I thought why why
hunt if you're not gonna like why would
you destroy houses yeah I you know
there's always a reason but it was
pretty tragic to see it get wounded and
get away because I was like what's gonna
happen and he was like well I was gonna
die in a hole somewhere get eaten yeah
or Dino yeah the thing about groundhogs
is that they knock trees down they can
destroy houses they can destroy
foundations so I was reading about it
and apparently there are some places
where if you actually catch the
groundhog you have to kill it
interesting because you can be liable
for the damage that caused after you've
caught it I did not know that crazy
right yeah well like imagine imagine you
catch it and they're like oh I don't
want to hurt the little thing so you
just bring it to the edge of your
property and let it go and go to your
neighbor's house and knocks a tree down
they're gonna be like you You released
that thing on me yeah someone mentioned
that about mice or like if you don't do
something with them they will come back
and they'll get worse and I was going to
say that I think that maybe one of the
best things about living on a ranch is
that you can teach your kids about the
circle of life like if something does
crawl in a hole and die then other
things come along and eat it it becomes
part of the soil it's all part of like
growing plants and all this really it's
actually really a neat cycle that I
think kids would benefit from knowing
about these things are hard because we
have led such like kind of privileged
and cushioned lives we can go to the
store and get these little pink things
that are they're chicken where did it
come from we don't know milk grows on
the shelves absolute Insanity we have no
connection to the things we eat it's a
good opportunity to teach kids about
that kind of cycle really important
would you butcher at the farm yeah I'd
butcher our stuff yeah I do yeah I do my
own boyfriend
yeah in fact this this discussion made
me think of my friend Shanna she always
says that cows are friends and steers
are food which is true you know like
cows have more babies and you eat the
steers and keep your replacement heifers
and sell some off and so anyway so there
is kind of a little bit of bifurcation
that's worth talking about like the the
cows themselves are actually in a in a
occupy a different place it's because
you keep them comfortable so they have
healthy babies and they produce good
milk well I mean you want to keep them
all comfortable ideally because you want
you know you want as much pound on the
animal as you can when you go to to
Butcher and if they're stressed out the
meat can be bad right uh yeah I mean
really stress is more just like though
how hard a time gaining weight at least
that's been yeah now like if you're
hunting
there yeah if you if you if you wound
something it's going to get a hit of
neurolepinephrine and then your meat is
going to be more tense and stiffer or uh
tough oh wow so yeah so when you're
hunting you wanna you want the animal to
go to be like in the head just down yeah
well yeah I killed as quickly as
possible like
and then there are some arguments people
will make that
uh like an arrow through and I've seen
it a bunch of times and
an arrow through the actual like boiler
room with the vitals the animal almost I
mean they'll run off but you can tell
they have no idea what happened you know
they're just like then they just die oh
wow so oh okay so then they don't get
the there's not a big loud sound
associated with it it's just a sharp
pain and then they're done so because
it's an arrow yeah Broadhead you know
it's just a clean cut in the bow doesn't
make a lot of noise and so I've heard
this argument I don't know how much I
don't know how much for like Bro Science
is going on there but I mean it's I
think it's a it's a viable argument I
think so like when you when when they
realize they're in danger they tense up
and then the muscle becomes stiff and
hard and then you try to eat it it's
like you gotta yeah I think the big hit
just the big hit of adrenaline yeah you
know going through and stiffens them up
yeah and and then you know of course
like if you hit something in the guts or
whatever then that's a whole nother you
kind of see that with factory farming
when they lead the cattle into the bolt
thing where they're gonna put the bolt
in their head and then you watch the one
behind it here the one in front of it Ai
and they freak out sure so that's got to
be affecting the final meat the meat
it's I mean I feel like I'm almost
disassociative I don't know I have I'm a
weird empathetic creature happy cows man
yeah happy cows happy but uh cows aren't
raised for beef is they're Dairy and
then what the steers are the beef cattle
uh cat uh yeah yeah yeah so cows are
kind of yeah cows are the females right
and they're gonna reproduce you know so
you turn your Bulls in depending on your
setup you're turning your Bulls in for
some people leave them in all the time
but you know you turn your Bulls in for
x amount of months and then you know you
pull your Bulls out and then like right
now at home most of us are Calvin or
almost done Kevin just having the babies
you know and then yeah your wean cows
and calves you know later on and that's
when they'll go to auction you know so
how long does it take for a calf to grow
up
it depends on your setup whether you're
running a cow calf operation or you're
running a feed operation or just like
buying Ballers or steers and uh it
depends on what you're doing but like
let's just say just for roundabout let's
just say eight months ish then you go to
auction or keep your replacement so if
if I wanted milk right and I bought day
one just born calf how long until it can
you know work with the ball to make
start producing milk and getting the
baby and everything I see uh usually
breed heifers around two years old two
years yeah are there any are they able
to in inbreed like chickens uh well I
mean you castrate all the the Bulls
right so you just have oh I see what
you're saying Dad yeah exactly uh yeah I
mean you try to avoid that while you can
but sure but some people will line burn
you castrate the Bulls well the bull
calves
you know so when you don't want them
because you only want one to be breeding
with them or what yeah well yeah you
don't you don't want a nine month old or
so bull calf out there breeding your
heifers or whatever right right right
right plus you know just makes better me
so there's like right so there's
specific specific bowls will be left not
castrated castrated but right yeah
you'll pull those out and put them in
their own pen and then those are the
studs yeah basically yeah that's a great
name that was interesting cow talk let's
let's go back to school or cow talk we
got the story from timcast.com
former assistant principal at Virginia
elementary school files a lawsuit says
critical race Theory teachings created
really hostile work environment really
Emily Mayas who worked at agnor hurt
Elementary School in Charlottesville
says she was subjected to extreme
harassment for weeks over her
reservations about CRT
the situation escalated for maez Mayas
she claims when she accidentally used
the word colored instead of people of
color during a teaching workshop despite
apologizing continuously including
immediately after the word was uttered
she says that for months she was
harassed and berated by other staff and
that the district failed to intervene
one black employee who refused to accept
the apology began referring to her as
that white racist bee wow you know I
just gotta say
this is a strategy to use if you work
somewhere with any kind of critical race
Theory stuff
so
that's what you got to do because if if
they're telling you things based on race
like white people white privilege or
whatever they're in violation of the
EEOC and civil rights act so you got to
assume this is this is that this is the
tactic you got to use it check out this
other story we got this one from Fox
News Professor wins lawsuit against
University over pronouns students demand
went against my Christian beliefs the
Ohio Professor won 400 000 after suing
the university over being forced to use
students preferred pronouns there it is
my friends
you got to stand up for yourself the
difference between the United States and
Canada right there how does the I still
my favorite part about the pronouns
thing is it should very rarely be coming
up in person conversation anyways
because you should most of the time
you're not using their pronouns when
you're actually talking to them in the
room anyways right you're you're gonna
call them by their name or you're going
to refer to them directly it's more to
control your speech when they're not in
the room that weird uh like we were we
we did a story on uh on pop culture
crisis where we we were talking about uh
Demi Lovato and Demi Lovato has like
they them pronouns and I couldn't do it
I kept screwing it up and because
because like you said earlier I want to
be respectful I I try to like some
people don't like that like I'm like
look that's what they want I understand
uh but I eventually like had to give up
on the point and come back to it like
the next day because I couldn't get it
right I couldn't I kept screwing it up
so she was controlling she I just did it
right there she they were controlling my
ability to speak on them without even
being in the room just by virtue of
creating Pro pronouns that are different
from the normal you know the normal set
so everybody called out Demi Lovato
because Demi Lovato says they are
Daddy's girl huh in caption of sizzling
Instagram portraits after coming out as
non-binary and using they them pronouns
you don't get to choose your pronouns
I'm sorry I got I got look I try to be
nice to everybody I want to be civil
respectful but you can't tell me what
words to use if I want to call Brett
Brott he can be like that's not my name
and I'll be like too bad like I'm gonna
say whatever I want I want now is that
short for bratwurst yeah
slightly differently delicious instead
of Ian I'm gonna call him hey you're not
the first what's he gonna do about it
just laugh so so if I say I'm you know
like Luke kept calling Lydia Linda yeah
rude first of all see well she's
offended I mean I have to take over
calling you Lydia Linda know Linda no
but like what's what's lady going to say
other than don't call me Linda he said
okay Linda like what are you what are
you gonna do it's like you can tell them
to be fair I think that pronouns are
very much a power play because Brett's
right there is no period of time at what
you would say like he when Braxton's
sitting right there in front of you or
when Tim's sitting right in front of you
it's when they're not even there it's
like could you could you imagine having
a conversation like that where you know
Brett makes a reference to a Demi Lovato
story and then I just look to Braxton
and I'm like did you hear what he was
just saying oh my gosh
I think if
if I mean rude for sure if someone
called me by the wrong name to make fun
of me I'd be like all right bro take it
easy and then if they kept doing it I'd
be like I'm not going to interact with
you anymore uh or or whatever I had to
do but I and it's so I understand why
but but then if I I change my pronoun to
a new kind of language or new kind of
thought thing that's a hard one to get I
don't I don't know maybe it's the same
kind of thing the emotionally for the
people that are experiencing this so
I don't know I don't know man it's well
like remember when it was on here or was
it on Rogan when the uh labontian and he
was talking about it's like yeah like
I'll call you by your pronouns but I
might just not call you very often to
hang out because you're really difficult
to be around like I don't mean any
disrespect but like if I have to worry
about any point in the conversation
something like this comes up I'm just
I'm just gonna check out dude I'm just
not interested I'm not interested in it
yeah good way to put it I mean how mad
are you at your dad you know like that's
like how much do you need attention yeah
I don't think it's that Demi Lovato said
she's Daddy's girl yeah she she you know
what I'm saying she why because she said
she's Daddy's girl yeah and now I've
look if she comes out and says that
she's non-binary I'm like okay whatever
if she comes out and says she's Daddy's
girl I'm like oh she's a girl again so
now she's a she right you can't like so
she changed it back so pronoun fluid
Yeah Yeah well yeah yeah she's just she
can just be pronounced no you don't
think it is the reason why they're going
after kids is because little kids are
like trying to find their identity right
but the identity is usually something
like do I want to be a fireman or do I
want to be a carpenter do I want to be a
doctor or a nurse or something now
they're going to kids and be like I
remember when I was little like what's
your favorite color and I was always
like I don't know like how do you know
what your favorite color is what does
that even mean and then I would just
tell people green because the calendar
of mar for March my birthday was always
greens like green I guess because like
that's the only thing I can kind of
think of I don't know I kind of like
blue or whatever
so you just pick it now you're a little
kid and they're like which pronouns are
you and they're like oh
floor bow
is it uh is it New York that recognizes
33 separate genders 31 31 separate
genders it's uh it's insane but that
they legally recognize any and all
genders which means you can make one up
on the spot so what is the point of the
31 if if they legally recognize all of
the 31 they even are redundant like
female to male is considered a gender in
in New York but FTM is also considered
gender even though it means the same
thing
this stuff is so difficult to talk about
because I am such a generally respectful
and do not want to offend or hurt
anyone's feelings and I know a lot of
people like working here you kind of
like P A lot of people see that as like
a flaw right that you're like you're too
weak to to stand up for something but
it's like I don't want to offend or
upset anybody but some of this stuff is
so impossible to process in the moment
that if I can't even have a a reasonable
conversation with you I don't know how
to do this without being offensive and I
don't want that so it's like I'm being
forced to be offensive but only to them
like I'm trying not to be but they're
making it about that and that's very
very difficult for me to process as
somebody who just doesn't want to be on
the wrong side of people just for
General reasons yeah talking about
someone that's that then you're then
you're taking some risks when you're
talking to someone it doesn't pronouns
are out of the question you don't even
use pronouns you're having a
conversation with somebody and anyone
can get down with that doesn't matter
how they identify when you start talking
about people then they're like well if
you're going to bring me into this bring
me into it the way I want to be brought
into it and that's like not in the
United States I'm bringing you in
because you're part of this uh and I
think it's you can have that discussion
it's it's purposefully destabilizing
yeah it's impossible for a regular
person to know what's happening or who
you're talking about so the example I
gave like on Twitter was I I can't
remember exactly how I wrote it but I
said Pat and Sam go to see a movie
they got angry
because they wanted to see a horror film
but they ended up seeing a comedy
instead and what they really wanted was
and then it's just like what is that
they refer to like which person did what
if you said like Mike and Jane went to a
movie she got angry because she wanted
to see a comedy film but he wanted to
see horror and they ended up seeing
horror now you understand the girlfriend
is mad she wants the comedy the
boyfriend want to see horror they were
both mad because I didn't I'm saying
anything but if you said Sam and Pat
went to the movies they were mad because
they wanted to see a comedy but they saw
horror it's like are you like they were
both mad
which which which person is referred to
in the they
now to be fair in the context of you
know Sarah and Jane go to the movie and
she was mad you're also like I don't
know which person you're referring to
because if it's two different genders
there you go in which in which case you
don't need the pronouns at all
Sarah and Jane go to the movies Sarah
got mad because because she wanted to
see a movie a comedy but Jane wanted to
see horror and they ended up saying so
you just use the name in which case this
whole discussion is like
I think you're right though that it is
that it's about being purposely
destabilizing as much as it pains me to
give him credit Jesse Kelly calls these
guys uh Communists all the time and I
think he's right at least in orientation
and also because it makes him mad to be
called communist so I think it's good to
use but uh the whole you know basically
the in a sense the Lenin model is
destabilized uh destabilize create
confusion and chaos and then come in and
be the person that restores order in the
way that you want it and that seems to
be the approach how did they restore who
who are they looking for people in the
streets but I'm saying who are they
looking for that's going to make sense
of this well at this stage at this stage
I don't think it matters because it's
chaos stage because he's like a lot of
these people who shield for for Biden
who just like like he doesn't understand
the stuff he doesn't like I would argue
that he doesn't really understand any of
the stuff that's going on with that type
of with that part of the movement but
it's like you said earlier you think
it's about destabilizing and we talked
about religion and you said I think like
why why does it feel like people are
coming more uh around to religion
against because they're looking for
something solid under their feet and I'm
not religious but I'm one of those
people that's like everything feels so
up in the air now that you're just
looking for something anything to hold
on to that feels like some semblance of
the real world and not this post-modern
hell that feels like we're in right now
I mentioned that earlier that in a time
when you start to lose faith in reality
you start to look for faith in other
places and I see people reverting to
religion of the past or to what
non-binary degenerism or whatever the
heck I looked up there's a meme going
around that says they translated
non-binary into Spanish and there's two
ways to translate it one is the feminine
version and one is the masculine version
perfect Wow
Let's talk about the return of religion
I mean uh you know Brett just brought up
that things are starting to become more
religious I remember reading about Dave
Rubin he is he now a Christian or do you
believe so yeah something like that
happened and I find that interesting
because a lot of people ragged on him
saying like all of a sudden this guy who
they say drifted to the right is now you
know all of a sudden he's a Conservative
Christian or whatever and the funny
thing is
the opposite kind of happens to me
because I've like long talked about how
I've believed in God since I was like 18
like I was grew up Catholic then kind of
drifted away but then I was a teenager
so I I you know had this like
realization and now I believe in God but
I don't consider myself like religiously
theistic or anything like that not
following I don't follow scripture or
anything like that I just think there's
a God
and instead I get conservatives calling
me an atheist I'm like why what is that
all about I don't know weird but I do
think it's interesting
um so I just wanted to dig in on why you
guys think religion is is making a
comeback uh fundamentally everyone is
Miss or um disoriented or misoriented
and as rudderless and unmored and we're
all feeling it it's the you know the
chaos is it's palpable you know and we
fill it in our own lives every day and
so everyone's looking for a Rudder the
rest like we're just adrift in the ocean
right now and we're looking for
something to stick in the waves and try
to get back to shore uh religion has
worked for a long time you know
Christianity is what two thousand years
old judaism's what five thousand years
old or something that's pretty firm
solid footing so I think it you know
people are looking that way because it's
worked I mean look like Pete the
Peterson phenomena but like he would
he would talk you know I've heard him
yeah Jordan Peterson thank you I've
heard him like be jokingly referred to
as like the guy who speaks to kids who
didn't have dads I mean maybe there's
some truth to that but I think really
like he was speaking to a generation
that was uh
sort of broken up by new atheism you
know like these these Christian these
younger Christian kids or Jewish kids or
whatever that fell in love with Dawkins
and Hitchens and Harris and these kind
of guys because they were charismatic
and really they're attacking the
argument level of like a a teenager or
whatever but they you know if you don't
know if you're not you know well steeped
or versed in your faith then it's kind
of easy to get you know swayed by
someone who's as charismatic it's
Hitchens so that went on for you know a
decade or whatever and then
these these people that had went through
that were looking at the society around
them and the chaos and disaster that it
had become and Peterson steps up and in
many ways is kind of like the anti-new
atheist he's like making similar
arguments but on the opposite end and
then those same kids like I remember
Peterson talking about a bunch of
atheists showing up but his his things
and asking them about God and so I just
think that we're looking for
uh collectively we're looking for some
solid footing and religion has persisted
so scientific method kind of turns me
off I know there's real value to the
scientific method it's fantastic for
building machines and stuff but placebo
effect is real no one knows why they
just know it's somewhat effective in
studies and trials that's not scientific
method can't explain it so that's not a
perfect system and so I look out I look
elsewhere what else is there quantum
physics is fascinating religions are
fascinating God is fascinating but to
jump on one seems like a a preemptive
mistake so at least that's where I'm at
right now
I I somewhat agree I do think the
scientific method can eventually
understand why the placebo effect
happens I think we just haven't yet
because if you're going to keep doing
testing you figure out what you know
what's going on in the brain or in the
body but uh I somewhat agree you know
picking one religion that's why I
consider myself
non-theistic in a sense I don't follow
any Scripture or whatever but I do
believe you know God exists and it's
it's because
there I've met too many people who are
like I know for sure and here's why let
me explain it to you and I'm like man
you really are convinced you know a
whole lot you've asked a lot of deep
philosophical questions and here's
another guy who says you're wrong who's
also very learned it has you know so I'm
like I don't know I think the one thing
I can agree on is that there's something
bigger and greater than all of us but I
don't know if like maybe maybe the
reality is everybody's looking through
the a small lens at the bigger picture
at the same thing and you know they're
looking through it and they see imagine
your look this is big mansion I was
using an example as a ballroom inside
with tons of people and they're all
dancing and and you look at the keyhole
they're like what do you see what's
inside and like there's a big woman with
a big dress then 10 feet down as a guy
looking through the same Keyhole and
he's like he sees a guy wearing a tuxedo
no it's not it's a guy wearing a tuxedo
and they both started arguing like oh no
no I I'm seeing this he's like he's
crazy look and everyone's like I can see
the lady he's making it up depending on
where you're coming from you see
something different but the reality is
the bigger picture on the inside is
everybody's getting little pieces of it
you know you think there's an objective
reality
yeah I do
how would you how would you define it
yeah well okay I mean seriously though
I'm so glad he asked you that question
well I mean oh Descartes makes me so
angry
um
uh yeah I mean I I see your point uh I I
think that it's a
you have to live in the real world at
some point and for me it's like uh that
that's a table and let's say I went
outside and closed my eyes and I I
didn't even know I had no idea you were
there it was it was in the dark okay you
knew I was there but I had no idea that
you were there and you threw a snowball
and hit me in the side of the face there
was no chance that I could deny the
existence of that snowball that I did
not know existed before it struck my
face
so like obviously we react with the
material world you know and I do think
it's it's provable it's just that it's
you have to set up such bizarre
experiments to get there that it's you
get in circles that this is why people
often argue about what objective and
subjective is and it's like you know
you've got the brain in the vet thought
experiment maybe your brain's in a tube
and they're poking with electrodes maybe
we're all in the Matrix maybe you at
home are the only real person and
everyone else is just some kind of video
game NPC who knows how do you define
objective reality ads it's the external
things that have a tendency towards
being true is the easiest way I can
think of it like if I throw a rock at a
standard house window the window will
will break or maybe you'll miss but we
can basically predict what's going to
happen physics physics is the most
objective reality I can figure at this
point sort of so the challenge is
some windows are bulletproof and so you
can be like I can prove to you objective
reality the window will break and you
throw it and then it bounces off the
window and you're like okay I was wrong
about that well it doesn't disprove
objective reality it just means there's
such nuance and subtleties to most
things that defining reality like
defining objective reality is is
difficult because everyone has a
subjective perspective I suppose you
just look for the things that everyone
agrees upon as being true which is why I
weighed the argument before about
Universal objective morality to which I
believe there is one and it's because
when we were talking to Jeremy uh boring
and Michael Knowles and they were saying
you know essentially what's the point of
a planet without humans it's because we
are human we live within a human
experience and The Human Experience is
our existence
without humans there's just you know
there's there's life but it's not
perceived the way we perceive it there's
no value to it the way we perceive value
it's literally just a rock and water or
something
so from The Human Experience I Look to
what is true in every culture to every
person
throw stepping out of rockets right so
we can see some things are objective but
it's a gradient you get to a certain
point where you're getting into physics
even and you might say I believe that
there are 13 Dimension here's the math
to prove it and someone else can be like
you're crazy there's 14 and here's the
math to prove it and then you're getting
into weird and Wacky World stuff because
they're both right you know if there's
14 that means there's also 13 there's
also 12. well but you get to my point
like they'll disagree on the math and
and you know ultimately the the
fundamental nature of the universe so
how could it be objective reality if the
Human Experience denies what is true
I'll tell you objective reality I gotta
go to the bathroom I will see you guys
in two minutes my point is not that
because too many a bunch of people
believe something is true
makes it true it's just that if we can
all prove something to a certain degree
and then we can replicate it we've found
our objective you know reality to a
certain degree it's never it's never
completely possible to know everything
why is the objective reality discussion
so fascinating like I'm literally asking
like why do you think it is that we
always come back to that when when we
have these discussions why is it that uh
this focus on uh like I was talking to
someone earlier about uh we always talk
about common sense not being that common
anymore it seems like people are taking
this uh a very large-scale view when
we've got plenty of problems in the very
very uh real world that we're dealing
with now so we have these discussions
and I always find that it ends up
distracting from actually solving not to
say that's not important or that there's
not value in the discussion there is but
I'm saying that it usually comes up when
we're discussing real world issues and
these other things so I'm always
fascinated how we go back to these kind
of more uh larger scale discussions
rather than staying on the topics we
were actually discussing beforehand well
I mean we're talking about people
becoming religious and that was to say
okay so like uh so for me like when I
was thinking about religion like as
somebody who's not uh not denominational
or anything like that but I keep coming
back to it recently because of an
absence of uh redemption in the world we
live in right now there's absolutely
like whether we're talking about people
who are like strong proponents of cancel
culture or if you want to talk about
ideological leftists that are pushing
these narratives right now they don't
really have much of a belief in
Redemption at all and that's something
we went and saw father stew which is
like uh like we reviewed it for the
channel and I was like I was like this
might have been like a six or seven
maybe but I gave it like a nine just
because seeing a story that was so
heavily focused on the idea of
redemption uh even if you exclude all of
the religious elements just that type of
of story is so missing and so lacking in
society today when you're not allowed to
be redeem yourself once you're once
you're out once you're on the outs with
the group you're out forever and you're
never allowed back that's why that's why
they say you can never apologize because
if you apologize you're admitting fault
and then you're forever that person and
that sickens me in a lot of ways I don't
like the idea that you're no that what
you are at one time is who you are
forever and I take issue with that and
religion takes pains to make that a big
part of its uh of its value system and
that means a lot to me even if I can't
at this time say that I'm denominational
yeah but again it goes back to the
communism thing they it's not that they
want you out as an outcast or whatever
forever they just want you broken submit
to the group yeah they just want you
broken so that they can mold you or use
you or throw you away or whatever and
then that is to your point uh the
Redemption Arc that uh
uh religion allows for is is powerful
and fundamental and in some ways kind of
what separates us from the Animal
Kingdom that we allow for things like
that maybe that's what's driving people
back to religion that they've seen
cancel culture they've seen the woke
left and they've and they've said I want
to be a better person I want to be I
don't want to be like that and so
there's a fundamental there's a moral
structure that says you can be redeemed
you can be forgiven which is the
opposite of the modern wokeness but uh
let's let's do this let's talk about uh
your book and uh your story you want to
explain what you know tell us what your
book is and what it's about yeah
um when I was I I joined the military
and then I got wounded over in Iraq and
it's uh in 2006 got busted up pretty
good broke on my left tibia my left
femur in three places and my left hip in
two places and my right hip and one and
my right femur and two and my radius and
ulnar and my arm and my right median
nerve got transected here and anyway
just you know a host of the injuries my
left humerus was broke and all by most
all by ball bearings and I do have a
hole down here but
um so then I I came home and I you know
it just ties into this Redemption Arc
I came home and they had me on uh you
know obviously they were having a hard
time they didn't know if I was gonna be
able to walk again and so I went through
all of that the physical recovery stuff
and then
um I got to a civilian doctor out it got
out of the military hospital to a
civilian doctor and he went through the
pain medication that I was on and he was
like Braxton I have women old women die
of cancer that are on way less than half
of the amount of pain medication that
you're on so I was hyper addicted to
opioids didn't know it at the time but
High predicted to opioids he started
scaling me back and then I went through
about two years of physical well first
stage physical therapy and then I
started trying to get off opiates you
know I just anyway so I went through
struggles with with all of that kind of
stuff and
um so you're speaking to Redemption Arc
I lived like a complete dirt bag for a
long time so I'm very I'm very Pro
Redemption myself I am I'm also in
recovery so that's a large part of my
story as well maybe that I didn't really
connect that when I was thinking about
it here but maybe that's why the idea of
redemption hits me so hard but I
understand that struggle for sure yeah
man so like prodigal songs right you
know he went off and lived in the
Underworld and now we're doing your best
to climb your way out or like as
Dostoevsky writes about it as like the
underground but it's it's the same it's
you know the underground man and
everything so it's the same concept
what's the book called The Glass Factory
is there so it's about your your
Redemption not coming back from Egyptian
and injury honestly one of my favorite
Parts about this book has been when I
first wrote it I was looking around and
all the war books that I was that I was
seeing were just not reflective of the
experience and it's like I'm not trying
to take a shot at anybody but they were
just not reflective of the experience I
was I was seeing around me I was seeing
my friends you know several of them
commit suicide getting divorces going to
jail losing custody or kids you know
having problems and the the two choices
in literature that they sort of had were
either Uber Hero Stories you know that
are
um anyway superhero type stories or this
this like very whiny you know crybaby
type thing and there was no one trying
to thread the needle and say look yeah a
lot of us are screwing up and you need
to quit screwing up and until you stop
screwing up your life is gonna suck man
like you gotta get out you know and do
better so I tried to kind of thread that
needle and
what was the moment you realized and oh
man
I don't know it's funny I actually wrote
about this in the book too you might
like you would this this part of the the
book you would actually like I was
trying to
you know you're doing a lot of
self-reflection when you're writing
something like that and I was trying to
find this this moment and pinpoint it
when I when I decided to like be better
or whatever and what I realized is that
we all do this when we tell our own
stories like we look back in time for
this one thing that flipped the switch
or whatever but it's never true there
was always a series of small decisions
that led up to or away from making the
right one what was a couple of the
really big decisions you made that led
you to the right to the path uh I mean
getting up at 5am helps for me it
doesn't work for everybody but just
getting myself onto a schedule was a was
a big one
um
what so I couldn't run for eight years
and then one day I was able to kind of
jog a little bit again and I used to be
you know be an athlete and so I really I
was very excited at the possibility of
running again so I went and ran a mile
with my buddy who's runs Insurance stuff
and then I decided to transfer that into
going and hiking the Mauna Kea in Hawaii
and so I had like a goal to train for
and that was that was enormous for me to
like have something to orient myself at
physically so that I actually had to
like take care of my body you know and
I'd gotten off of the opiates before but
then I was just you know still living
like an idiot and drinking too much I
want to ask for for both of you guys
actually you know being in recovery did
uh religion or God play a role in in
getting off drugs
I mean for me for sure it was uh
I would say
the drug part well I was so lost still
at the time
um that I'm not sure how much God really
I mean God so this is where it gets hard
is like maybe to my own neurotic selfish
uh you know in my own neurotic and
selfish mind God wasn't playing a role
but I think you know looking back I
think for sure God was playing a role
and now it helps a lot
I didn't have uh any uh subjects I don't
know if I would have been able to
process that type of a concept at the
time my brain was in such chaos going
through that but for me it was uh and
like we I was just discussing with
someone with this hello there's no
linear like everyone looks for that
moment where they feel like they're
getting better or like this is the big
decision it's in the movies it's always
somebody uh gets in a car accident and
they realize they have to turn their
life around but for most people it's not
something that concrete you just have to
make that decision day by day and then
suddenly find yourself on a path to do
so and for me it wasn't religion so much
as it was getting uh finding firm
footing on something I wanted to do was
like skating for me it was uh I had been
sober for a while and then my mom passed
and then that wasn't an event that led
to it but it changed things as far as my
schedule and my ability to open up my
life because I was at that time I was
taking care of my mom she was in poor
health for many years so the ability to
get back out in just physical activity
played a huge role in that and like you
start uh you know actively getting
active again you feel better about
yourself and that leads and it all
becomes kind of like a snowball rolling
downhill uh and it's just uh it wasn't
God for me but it was more the ability
to take your life into your own hands uh
and push forward was very um
Monumental when you've been at the mercy
of something for so long the ability to
be in control of yourself again is uh I
guess I've told that story before like
when I when I realized that I could go
outside without uh or like I could get
up without being sick I cried I cried
for 20 minutes and that's because you've
now got control of yourself again you're
not beholden to something created by a
pharmaceutical company uh and that's a
revelatory experience that goes far like
I mean maybe that is uh uh God speaking
in a way but it certainly it feels to be
akin to that
I'm thinking about the brain and all the
the neurons and if that's connected to
the magnetosphere the extremely low
frequency band that's God and are you
part of it yeah you know that's what I
normally think about yeah self-control I
imagine if there is a God that it's
tightly interwoven I just wonder because
I hear a lot of stories that you know a
religious experience or something was
like force pulling people I tell the
story about this guy I knew who's you
know who's on drugs and then he had a
profound experience where a voice told
him to get his life together and it made
him very religious I looked for
something like that you know like maybe
it's just because like I I talk about
pop culture all day I watch movies all
day I'm looking for that movie-like
experience that's going to bring me out
of the the situation I'm in and then one
day you just realize that is not the
real for at least not for everyone it
won't be the real world it won't be what
everybody experiences and you have to
rely on yourself again and uh maybe it
would have uh maybe selfishly I would
have loved to have had that but I still
had such a hard time asking those
questions about uh Faith like uh it's
very hard for me to put my Faith all in
something so perhaps he had a different
belief system that led him more to find
something like you know to find his
answers in that and I just hadn't
whatever wherever I was on my journey
just wasn't there yet so I had to find
my way a different way but it's like
that's that movie type way you always
imagine somebody pulling you back
um from the brink and that's just that
wasn't my experience but I almost would
have loved to have had that it feels
like that would have uh that would have
been benefit I think at the root of
every addict it fundamentally is in
gratitude for being you know it's like
just being angry at being so if you try
to cultivate gratitude in your life and
uh you know take yourself and and
however you want to think about this
bone sack that you occupy uh take start
to take that seriously then a lot of
your other problems will sore themselves
out uh we I used to talk about gratitude
as a superpower the ability to show
gratitude for uh at a certain point I'm
in a very cheap apartment I'm working
I'm barely making enough money to get by
but I'm skating every day and I'm doing
what I love and if I can go out every
day walk to get around do what I need to
do do something that I love while having
a job paying my bills and if I can be
extremely grateful for that that is
something that I feel like I feel bad
for people that can't find the Gratitude
you know like I almost feel like they're
missing out on the ability to to feel
that uh that emotion what's the best way
to find gratitude through pain
uh for me I I don't know if I find it
through pain I find it through getting
through the pain and finding yourself on
the other side of it and that's the
ability to handle it without help or
like without uh the ability to find
yourself through it and still be okay
not without help but like the ability to
you know to suffer through it achieve uh
you know get out on the other side and
find out that you're still okay and you
can still go on there's gratitude in
that for me one of the best parts about
that is that we all embody that lesson
and we don't realize it like when you go
to the gym and lift weights you have
pain and you know it's sort of a
suffering experience and you do that
because you know that on the other end
you're going to be a stronger person and
we've known that since we were little
you know we learned this slowly over
time you know your your literally
embodying that uh that story you know
yeah let's go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the share
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com become a member if you want
to support our journalists and you'll
get access to the upcoming members only
show we'll be live around 11 p.m on the
website but let's read some super chats
let's see Ginger mcisaac says happy tax
day everyone cough cough wheeze I'm just
gonna say it you know uh super chats
were low for the for this show but I get
it I get it I get it and so you know
like we've got the console here at the
YouTube for the for the YouTube studio
and I'm looking at the revenue and it's
it's not bad it's like we we do well but
I'm just like everybody's hurting pay
your taxes everybody everybody just
cashed that big check and they're like
oh Lex frame them in an interesting
tweet he was like I'm down I'm paying my
taxes I'm crying but I I wish I knew
where this money was going I don't like
sending it to this amorphous blob of a
thing that is bureaucratic and he makes
a fantastic point I I I think we should
have some sort of transparent mechanism
to decide where at least some of our tax
money goes even if they say all this is
going to Black budget at least I know
well I mean they can be like you know
you submit an inquiry I'd like to know
where my you know x amount of dollars
and taxes went and then like they just
send you back a form it says we blew up
kids yeah you know that's what it feels
like it's a bit dark because the war the
military budget is not as high as people
think it is everyone I think it's like
probably 20 of the dollar that you spend
in taxes maybe that's that's maybe I'm
wrong about that because I I think
people think it's really high it's not
as high as I think and a lot of it does
go to like I think veterans benefits I
think people need I think that's true
like a large portion might go to like
it's like 120 billion of it I think yeah
yeah I think the the majority of the the
budget is uh social programs
um yeah nearly positive you guys know
how much what the tax revenue is for the
year or like what it was last year
Google it yeah and then we'll read some
super chats while you Google it thank
you I want to know who's gonna sorry I
just want to know who's going to click
the gender training you know or
diversity training when they're filling
out their tax form if you know if we go
under Ian system oh like how many people
are really going to click like yeah
let's find more of this you know exactly
it would be interesting yeah yeah it
would be gone people are gonna be back I
don't know it would be like healthcare
and everyone looked like yes and then
it'll be like war no and it would be
like gender studies no it looks like it
right yes 2021 they expected in October
they had expected to estimates were 3.8
trillion
he said 180 billion go to okay that's
not that much 3.8 can you look at them
can you look at the breakdown for how
where it goes yeah I think it's 120
billion to the VA but I could be getting
that number wrong let's read some more
we got Delhi who says Tim Felix Rex AKA
black pigeon speaks is currently in the
US I beg you not to let the opportunity
pass without getting him on timcast IRL
would be a great conversation especially
around geopolitics I don't think we can
because I don't believe that he shows
his face much on camera I haven't caught
up with him lately I did I do think he
did a face reveal but I don't think he
would be comfortable with coming on and
giving an interview but I got a chicken
mask downstairs you could wear like 100
yeah you know put a mic into the all
right user not available says Tim you're
looking good thank you I like the
haircut also Ian looks like the teacher
from Biebs and Butthead in a good way
put a pic of him next to Ian thank you
should we get the teacher and we'll put
it on them
teacher yeah all right I mean and kind
of acts like him too yeah that guy's so
funny what was his name let's find out
all right
Joe harsh Barger says Peter Ducey why do
you still recommend masks saki for God's
sake Peter I'm a press secretary not a
doctor
Star Trek
all right I got the name it's David Van
driesen van driesen a hippie teacher at
Highland High School yeah
did you see the article I put in uh I
sent the other day about the person who
said they'd only come back for DS9 if it
was about social justice oh jeez who
said that uh one of the one of the
actresses from the show I saw I saw a
really interesting post earlier that
said
it was it was breaking down how people's
lives were like in the United States
completely revolving around Christianity
whether they realize they're not even
atheists and one of the funny points was
that your your favorite exclamation is a
call to your lord and savior people
literally will yell Jesus when they're
shocked by something do you not realize
that I mean people people really don't
think about it we see these videos of
people yelling Allahu Akbar when like a
bomb goes off and people are like what
is it what is it like it's like they're
saying oh my god that's literally like
probably the best translation it's like
it means God is great like yeah but the
probably the emotion is oh my God and so
some I just said geez which is just
derivative of Jesus even atheists in
this country will be like you'll yell
Jesus Christ when something absurd like
a car will hit a dog and you'll yell
that out I've been wondering why they
call him Jesus because it's Yeshua I
think in uh Aramaic is that the right
language yeah which is basically Joshua
yes
hey I figured out where the money's
coming from uh from the 3.8 trillion but
I can't figure out where it's going uh
not yet anyway but it's 1.9 trillion
comes from individual income tax 1.3
trillion comes from payroll tax and
that's the bulk wow just 284 billion
came from corporate income tax on this
tax day
this auspicious of holidays let me just
say that um
they tax you on the money you earn they
tax you when you spend it you have to
pay a tax for simply owning a house they
tax you on the car you purchase they tax
you on the gas you put in it they tax
you on not just the food you buy but
specific items get extra taxes
they tax everything I think people don't
understand this that
it's like for the average person what is
it like 50 to 55 percent of your income
goes to taxes because they look at
income tax and they're like that's my
taxes but they don't realize you bought
a cheeseburger a portion goes to the
government you bought a house and I got
to pay the government ever you got to
pay government rent
the other thing too is that payroll tax
oh that's brutal that means you and your
employer are splitting I think it's 15
percent
so the employer pays 7.5 and you pay 7.5
they are jamming taxes everywhere
I mean they revolted because of a
taxation no taxation without
representation if you don't know where
your money's going that's a big problem
taxes all right all right I'm trying to
find out too income tax is relatively
new in our country's history as far as I
can say yes in the 1917 I think yeah
yeah and it was like Federal Reserve it
was a it was a tiny percentage only for
like the ultra wealthy it's supposed to
be temporary too right yeah they
incrementally increased it increased it
like they slowed the water the heat of
the water up to boil the people I mean
geez is it unconstitutional I don't know
they changed the Constitution to make it
legal death tax someone brought up death
tax oh yeah so like after you've already
paid all your taxes then you die the
government comes and takes even more
that's crazy look man how did nobody say
like maybe we're going like just for
like uh like morale's sake maybe we
shouldn't tax them after death like
just give him that man come on well it's
because you're dead you can't complain
like maybe the family members might just
be a little bit perturbed well you guys
know I'm I am not a taxationist theft
guy but at a certain point geez yeah
it's like you know I could I can
understand a little bit but we're we're
overpaying it's like imagine if Netflix
came to you one day and they were like
uh we're raising your rates to 100 a
month you'd be like whoa whoa whoa hold
on there a minute I'm gonna opt out um
you can't and what if I don't want to
pay for never see more we will lock you
in a box it's like all right now not got
an issue with how much money you're
taking from you by force like some money
I think is reasonable for all this
awesome stuff that we end up having
especially security the military hey I'm
not I'm not completely opposed to
well hold on Luke Luke and Luke of we
are changing the chat saying why in the
world is no one saying taxation is theft
Luke Luke did Luke see the uh the meme
that came out on Easter it's the three
crosses outside the church and it's the
uh they're all teas and it spells
taxation it's theft I'll put it this way
it's like yo if I if I have Netflix and
it's you know 10 bucks a month I'm like
that's reasonable I I think it's fair
like I'm getting this service although I
I don't have Netflix now because Netflix
is weird and creepy but like if I was
going to get a subscription service I
got no problem paying for it but if they
came to me one day and they were like
your subscription service is now 10
times more expensive I'd be like you're
stealing from me yeah like better yet
they charge your bank account without
notifying you and you don't know why
they took the money or where it's going
and they didn't break it down and then
when you say hey I I challenge this you
can't do that they go if you don't pay
it we're gonna lock you in a box yeah
okay yeah if you want to go in the box
then we'll shoot you yeah right if you
won't go in the Box I guess the argument
of why taxation isn't theft Luke and
everyone else that thinks that is that
they're they're protecting you you pay
it's basically since the Middle Ages
they go around they take a little bit of
the food the farmers make or a lot of it
unfortunately and then they protect the
farmers from record Invaders I get that
and I agree but my point is like up to
that point I'm like yeah you know that's
cool like I like the military like cool
dudes but um well I mean now with all
the woke stuff happening I'm not so sure
but but when if like someone came to me
and said hey it's 100 bucks a month for
the security that we're gonna be
providing because we're all pitching in
I'd be like that's cool if one day that
guy showed up to my house and and like
smashed a flower pot and says you got to
give me more money if you want to be
safe I feel like I don't think you're
protecting me anymore so it's just a
protection racket you have to give them
the money in an envelope and you guys
don't like the fact that they're using
this money to pay Foreign Wars I don't
like the fact that they're using this
money to pay for stuff that I don't
agree with I'm pro-life they're using it
to fund abortions what gives this is my
money that they're taking for me to do
this kind of stuff I don't know no it's
just like you're right it should be
decided from the ground up exactly
there's a guy and he's like so uh your
monthly bill for your road subscription
includes a surcharge for killing babies
blowing up babies overseas for making
the weapons that kill the baby this is
the Drone tax this is the Drone tax here
it's like all I wanted was police in a
fire department and they're like oh yeah
yeah but we got all these fees we gotta
add on and then you're like all right
well can I add Healthcare no sorry we
don't offer health care it's like but
the roads so like that that's the thing
it's you know if I could trade a lot of
if I could if I'll tell you this if if
we could itemize the tax list I'm sure
we could take out a huge chunk and like
put in the garbage and then take like a
little tiny bit and you get health care
back for it yeah I'm not saying
universal healthcare outright for
everything I'm saying a little bit sure
a little if you guys want to know who's
in charge of this uh who created this
income tax IRS form 1040 it was William
Howard Taft from 1909 to 1913 he was our
president damn it right when the Federal
Reserve was formed I mean it's just part
of the racket this corporate let's let's
read some more Super chats here all
right we got um
arth amisia says if you have to if you
have to ask a biologist about gender
does that mean gender is biological yes
and if you have to ask a gen saki about
masks does that mean and she's not a
doctor does that mean masks are an issue
for a doctor
yes good point
Adrian Contreras says I cannot compete
with the Majesty of your beard sir I
will shave mine in disgrace
all right invisible buds uh invisible
dud says Matt Walsh in an alternate
reality quote what is a man answer this
guy's beard
oh my word
all right Jonathan Munoz says look up an
old whitest kid You Know sketch bike up
the a it is a great sketch that portrays
reality now where you can't have an
opinion on something unless you are an
expert oh really that's that's fine as
kids you know y'all check it out
all right
tnhp podcast says Tim if you're all
right with this question has anyone on
your team besides your self-received
death threats and if they're comfortable
with explaining I don't know
I don't know I don't think so so I think
it's just me yeah nothing like that uh
plenty of people that aren't happy uh
with like where I work uh people who
just you know
I've been making YouTube videos since
2006 and yeah you get the most stupid
comments and messages from people if
you're putting your face on the internet
and speaking it's just part and parcel
to the entertainment industry that's why
Paramount Pictures as giant walls
surrounding their their work environment
because people come even if it's not
like a death threat people coming and
mobbing you to say hello is also a sort
of threat to your ability to move around
so you need to protect your environment
it's a new genre of art man it's we got
to take care of ourselves and it's not
just that it's you know people think
whenever whenever someone comes up
they're like those leftists and I'm like
I gotta be honest it's probably just a
guy who thinks that I invented the piano
and that I'm hoarding Ivory to take over
Mount you know Bigfoot and so he's the
only one who can save the world from the
pending Sasquatch Invasion by stopping
me like just nonsense like crazy people
sounds amazing yeah that whole pitch was
just I own that IP not Bigfoot The
Invasion pianos I own it the ivory yeah
yeah actually someone should make that
that'd be great play us out Bigfoot
Bigfoot's not real oh
all right David Fitzsimmons says missed
last show live so I want to say that say
Daryl Davis is the Sun and hate speech
laws are the wind in the parable to make
a man disrobe his coat I'm not sure what
that Parable is what is that one so the
sun warms people it makes them shed
their Shields whereas the wind makes
people tighten up and hate oh I see yeah
all right
Rob mats is happy to see you all made it
safely back home also please get Randall
Carlson on would love to would love a
chill podcast for once and you should
look up Tim pool lose it and attacks a
guest by ping trip I don't know what
that is what is that I lose it in a tax
guest is that like a funny edit where I
fight somebody I agree with Randall
Carlson he's a geologist he's been
studying the flood Theory from 13 000
years ago at the end of the younger
driest be a great Friday guest Conti
says Tim have you seen airline ticket
prices was looking up for my family of
four and the ticket cost 36 000 plus
what 36. whoa I mean we we've yeah
ticket prices are a lot
but we'll see we'll see how things go I
I think that um
the economy is is going to continue to
implode housing prices I don't think
will come down I'm not a financial
expert I'm not an economist but just
based on a lot of stuff that I've seen I
think I think houses aren't going to
come down because the cost material
costs are way too high so they probably
can't come down a bit but not as much as
people are expecting there's gonna be a
crash I don't know man try try building
a house right now see I might see how
expensive it is I wonder if it gets to
the point where somebody owns so many
houses and they can't sell any of them
because no one has the money or can
afford it and then the houses start to
rot so they're like we need to drop the
prices and get these things out
otherwise we're just losing money but
you're saying they might demolish it
further resources in Ukraine the cost of
a house or like a studio will be three
hundred thousand dollars and a Ukrainian
earns something like 400 per month so
they can never buy it what do they do
all the oligarchs that on the property
rent it out
so you've got permanent tenants who have
no choice no and the rent is not that
high but the buildings aren't in great
shape but the people have no choice yeah
you could argue that having corporations
maybe should only own a certain number
of houses that any Corporation cannot
own more than a certain number of houses
what if what if we like as a as a people
like Collective just you know
what's the right word maybe seized the
means means of what of production oh oh
disease the means of production yeah
interesting idea I like I like the idea
like I think it's funny they call it
seizing the means of production because
like who is seizing it like we are no
you're not
Caesar dude and what are the means of
production they mean the kulak I mean
well this is funny because I got an
argument with socialist once and I was
like what does that mean the means of
production and they're like you know
like the things to make stuff and I was
like is my camera the means of
production because I make videos and
they're like well
I I guess and I'm like so then someone
would take my camera from me and they're
like well I don't know it's your camera
and I'm like what are you talking about
then they get into the private property
versus personal property
nonsense and what about the stuff that's
in your mind you know because that's
part of the means of production we will
take your brains neural net coming yeah
they're they're zombies
all right
wandering Mage says what do you think of
the belief that we need a complete
societal collapse to fix our corruption
and other societal ills that there's no
cultural change we can make to fix our
society in the long term I hear this
view a lot uh well I don't completely
disagree I think that um we as a society
have become particularly addicted and
there's a lot of I don't know there's a
lot of stuff that's ingrained that is
bad the the issue is it's not so much
about Society breaking down to fix it
it's that the like two factions have
butted off and split from each other
I think the left is a destructive
chaotic force that seeks nothing I think
it's just power for the sake of power
change for the sake of change people
saying random nonsense things for the
sake of fitting in with the current
thing and then that's actually separated
itself from where we are which is not
overtly conservative it's more like
principled libertarian conservative-ish
with a spattering of different
ideologies mixed in but retaining a
baseline of a moral framework and a goal
so I don't think study needs to collapse
but there might may need to be some kind
of peaceful divorce where the chaotic
destructive force goes off and just
spirals out and burns out or something I
mean you don't want to collapse I can
tell you that I saw a collapse in Iraq
it is not good I mean it is people don't
get it yeah it is ugly very ugly it like
a collapse means finding your uncle in a
dump you know and you're a kid in a
ditch I mean that's what collapse means
wait I mean look it collapse could mean
if you're out in the middle of nowhere
and you've got a farm waking up one day
to a bunch of hipsters running off with
your chickens because roving bands of
urban who don't Urban liberal types who
don't know how to survive are just
ransacking also fire I mean geez are we
under undervalued the danger of fire and
what people can do to a city if they
want to light it on fire that's collapse
you don't want that you saw it you saw
it oh yeah I'm agreeing with you for
sure
yep I saw a meme One Time by the way I
got to bring this up and it said uh who
would win a cow and a lantern or the
entire city of Chicago yeah
my favorite meme
that's what it is yeah I think that's an
earth like an apocryphal probably but
that's a good story what is the exact
story Mrs O'Leary's he has Mrs O'Leary's
cow uh the Great Chicago Fire it was
1900s yeah she was like milking it or
something right and kicked the lantern
out of him yeah you know most a lot of
people on Earth that don't have
electricity still burn kerosene it's so
dangerous not only they breathe it in
but it's a fire hazard I mean it's a lot
of people wow all right just some guy
says Tim I was halfway to Tears by the
end of your conversation with Michael
and Jeremy in the best way can't
describe it maybe I needed to hear that
conversation and felt God thank you
great P.S Jean-Luc Picard for a silky
rooster that's pretty good
that was that was a really fun
conversation we had with Jeremy uh
Jeremy boring and Michael knows the
daily wire asking these questions about
philosophy like and ethics if you if
there's a raging River and there's your
dog or a stranger who would you save if
you could only save one and a stranger
The Stranger yeah the the interesting
question that the reason that came up is
that it used to be that Americans always
would say the stranger but now they say
their dog and I'm wondering if that's
mental illness I asked the question no
one really could answer that but is it a
form of mental illness that people would
protect their pets over a stranger
yeah probably yeah yes it's it's
definitely mental illness and it's just
it's also just reflective of how much we
hate each other yeah you know I I think
I think maybe I would describe it as a
natural aberration in that I don't think
you're ill because you love your pet and
you want to save what you care about
there's also a point that
humans and dogs survived together so
there's an element of survival in an
attachment to a dog the issue is that
we've come to a point where in this case
the dog is probably a toy poodle which
is not going to help you survive at all
but the emotional attachment comes from
the days of humans hunting with Proto
dogs which are effectively wolves now
wanting to save your Proto dog or your
your German worship or something yeah
well it's like that dog is helping you
hunt sniffing things out you're
surviving without it you could be in
trouble so you need your dog but now
we've artificially selected dogs down to
like Chihuahuas and someone's gonna be
like 50 and they're gonna jump in the
river and save the little toy poodle and
the person isn't it gonna make it or how
many people would save their car or the
stranger let me just let me just say
even going back to those periods where
it was your your dog versus the person
the person would help you survive more
the reason I'd say it's an aberration is
that I think it comes from a good place
but whatever it is this mentality that's
taking over will result without some
kind of intervention technology clear
otherwise in human civilization
collapsing because you cannot survive if
you don't prioritize your own people
your own species
in the event of a catastrophe then
humans just won't it's a mathematical
equation over a long enough period of
time humans who do not prioritize humans
will cease to exist no so I heard a
similar one one time really quick that
uh they it was a psychological
experiment they put together and it was
if you were wearing your nice clothes or
whatever and you saw a kid drowning like
you're wearing a suit and expensive
shoes or whatever would you just jump in
to save the kid or would you take off
you know your suit or whatever to do it
and it was the the breakdown was like an
enormous amount of people were like yeah
I would take off my suit or my watch or
whatever the heck it was the suit I
could take your iPhone out of your
pocket because you can't swim right
exactly yeah the shoes I take off so I
could get web my web toes out there but
like if their phone in their pocket
would they take their time to get their
phone out of their hand check if they
have email before they set it down they
take that their phone they selfie them
and the kids screaming yeah and they
throw their phone down that's what would
actually happen I still get one for the
gram well you see do you see that story
about the woman who got raped on a train
no in front of people they'll just
pulled out their phones oh my gosh where
was it what country how did it in the
United States I just didn't want you to
say that pretty sure it was New York I
don't know they'll Google it Google it
it may have been New York and everyone
just starts filming and I'm like but I
mean
nobody wants to fight and and I'll tell
you I'll be honest I don't know if I
would intervene you know why
because you will go to you will go to
jail yeah you'll get accused of being
you know racist or of of excessive force
and so what do you do you can't be armed
I'll tell you this in West Virginia I
got nothing to worry about if I see
someone attacking somebody I'm gonna
intervene carefully very carefully but
you've got a lot less to worry about
when you're acting defensive other here
in others here versus places like New
York was it New York uh Philadelphia
October 21 and uh this on the SEPTA
train people just pulled out their
phones man
all right bad Adam says Brett I'm a Pang
member of timcast why can't I watch full
episodes of Pop Culture crisis on the
timcast website I don't think I should
have to go to Spotify to watch a full
episode ask Tim I have uh long suggested
that we should um
we um we were talking about uh I wanted
to put the full episode like the video
version of the episodes up uh originally
I wasn't sure if it was because of uh
YouTube or rumble or what or whatever we
were taught we talked about it at one
point about long-form content because we
do we our show's live yeah and yours is
recorded yeah so I was like how would we
structure that with the clips yeah but
for the website we should just put it on
we should use Rumble I would be I that's
I one of the first things that I wanted
to do like once we got to a certain size
was that we would include that just
because I think that it would be good
for uh I always like push it like
whenever I'm pushing the Spotify link
I'm like it's all the witty banter that
you can because like when we cut the
segments up I tend to like trim down
areas like okay the conversation really
stopped here before we moved into this
subject so let's let's put them on
Rumble yeah
change has been made we will we will we
will hopefully be doing that very very
soon you guys are involved in the
creative process is uh is Mary doing
articles is she going to be doing
articles right now uh we're just still
working to get dig get through the
format and get everything organized
every day we've got a good structure now
what she's been doing is she goes on to
the the Cesspool of Twitter which I just
do not dare to go uh because I I just I
just I don't life is too short uh and I
just I don't Twitter uh uh so she goes
and she'll like like like look at this
is happening today like she was Finding
Me stuff at Coachella that I would never
have uh talked about and so she'll
curate some stuff for me and we may
eventually uh turn that into article
writing where she can be like look at
all these people are having this
discussion uh and then write her piece
about it and then we can involve that in
that process but once we get there we'll
uh we'll make that work Megan Cole says
my husband works in customer support for
a small jet company he said the air
isn't recirculated it is brought in from
outside side and pressurized for you to
breathe and there's a process for taking
it out of the cabin you are not
breathing the same air that's
interesting good you want you guys want
to know a trick when you're flying
commercial you ever notice that people
fart a lot on airplanes
because the pressure so they start
farting like crazy some people they got
it bad so what you do is you turn on the
air vent but you point it down to your
right creating a force field of air that
repels they're not just coming they're
not just gases all right I learned
something truly wonderful today it's
like the ball at the waterfall the smell
gets stuck on the flowing air and just
revolves there and it sits right on that
person's face and then when they're
going oh oh you're like you've done this
yourself
all right
Murph try says
Brent really enjoyed you and Mary's
review of Father Stu plan on seeing it
soon Tim four Flags in the room if a kid
brought in a Papal flag it would leave
the teacher speechless like you know the
thing Michael Knowles so I said on
Twitter
we should have uh teachers should teach
kids have religious studies in schools
these kids have questions and teachers
should be allowed to answer them
teachers should also tell the kids to
keep their religious studies a secret
from their parents hmm imagine if we had
done that there to don't say religion
don't say God don't say God don't say
God bill
I actually do think teachers should talk
about religion
um and the funny thing is the response I
got when I tweeted that was they were
like you know trans people are real and
you can't talk about fake things and I
was like when did I say anything about
trans people when did I anything say
anything about a specific religion when
did I say the teachers would tell these
kids the religions were true quite
literally I think of kids like someone
told me this is God it's like oh yeah
well we should talk about religions of
the world why wouldn't you teach kids
about various religions and then if if
one kid's like wow that religion's
interesting it's like well you can go
talk to your parents about it you know
but like basic understanding of that I
see no issue with and that's where they
get you on the um
on the the lgbtq stuff is they're trying
to pretend like I'm just trying to let
them know that people love each other
but then you see the books they're
pushing through and you see like the
things they're telling kids you're like
that's that's it's entirely different
telling a kid that there is something
bigger than all of us that's hard for me
to explain because I'm not a priest but
definitely talk to your parents about it
why there are people all over the world
who do these things it's very different
from like human sexuality but even still
the point was more facetious like if
you're gonna ban this you know if the
progressive parent comes into the school
and says why are you teaching religion
in your school you say I don't know I'm
not a priest
there you go all right let's grab a
couple more here
Mr Big Bird says Yeshua was
transliterated there was no yeah so it
became IA shua uh oh I'm sorry shua was
a feminine name suffixo became sus the I
later turned into J and the
pronunciation shifted
I remember the first time when I was a
little kid I saw someone named Jesus
and I was like oh I didn't understand I
was like really young and I was like
what is your parents name you Jesus he's
like my name's Jesus and I was like does
that mean Jesus I'm like oh cool like
Joshua yeah all right let's see we got
here last one Jeremy Lewis says
Brooklyn Democratic Party leaders are
trying to prevent uh prevent rep your
black candidates from serving on the Dem
County committee what does your block
rep your block candidates oh sorry uh on
the Democrat County Committee in
coordinated filing of objections
blocking common people from being
Democratic candidates candidates of
course they don't want what happened to
the Republican party to happen to them
that would freak them out all right
ladies and gentlemen if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and head over to timcast.com
become a member because we have a
members only show coming up it'll be
published around 11 pm and you won't
want to miss it as a member you're
keeping our journalists employed and
that is that's that's the end goal and
and doing shows like pop culture crisis
and expanding the business it's all
thanks to you guys as members so we are
doing a lot we have a lot of we have
some big updates
one of the things we're doing behind the
scenes right now is we're we are I'll
just put it this way participating in
creating resilient infrastructure to end
cancel culture I'll have more to say on
this in the coming days but uh what
trust me when it's it's not just about
the content it is about everything we're
doing from the bottom up
we are we are doing some restructuring
in terms of the website in a way that
will help counter the big Tech powers
and control so we'll explain this in you
know in due time but maybe even this
week we'll be able to have an update for
you on that so again timcast.com uh
Braxton do you want to shout anything
out yeah uh you can find me on Twitter
uh braxmikoy.com if you're interested in
uh do like learning uh stuff about
mountains and first aid and going
hunting and that kind of stuff you can
go to bunkhouse.brex mccoy.com and sign
up and we've got a course list there and
more courses to be set up here in the
next couple weeks right on
uh guys you cannot find me on Twitter
because life is too short but you can
find me on Instagram at Brett dasovic
but also please go to the YouTube
channel and follow pop culture crisis
there uh we just had our 100th episode
that will be coming out tomorrow we are
very excited uh the show is growing and
it's it's been a joy for me really an
honor and a pleasure it's also on
Spotify uh Amazon music Apple podcast
all those formats just uh go and follow
the show and uh thank you guys so much
uh Ian Crossland check me out at Ian
crossland.net if you want to get in
touch or follow my stuff Braxton good to
meet you man you too man I want to
remind people point to the glass at the
Glass Factory yeah you can pick that up
on Braxton mccoy.com or Amazon thanks
man yeah thank you appreciate you thanks
very much for coming this evening
Braxton I do have to say that Brett is a
great host of uh pop culture crisis I am
on there on Wednesdays we have a lot of
fun we pull up a few articles that we
don't usually cover on Ira which is
always great I love to like change
things up a little bit and talk about
something different you guys may follow
me on Twitter and minds.com at sour
patchlitz as well as sarahpatch lids.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
before you go make sure you check out
youtube.com chicken City I think the
funniest thing was that when we were
hanging out with Brett Cooper from the
daily wire I you know they come into the
trail and I'm like have you seen chicken
City and she's like oh I was watching
that earlier and I was like oh cool I
didn't realize that was you guys just
popped up on YouTube I started watching
it because it's relaxing and I'm like
yes
you know the the meme uh the joke is
that people are saying they want chicken
City to get more concurrent viewers than
Joe Biden on his next speech or whatever
and I'm like it's a joke but it would be
good for chicken City so I will accept
it all right everybody we'll see you all
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out bye guys